The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BRADY ENSTAD: Hi,
everybody, we're Team Paul.
I'm Brady Enstad,
and I've primarily
been the interviewer
for the project.
LEXI DIEN: I'm Lexi Dien, and
I've primarily the videographer
and video editor.
YI ZHONG: And I'm Yi Zhong.
I've been the lead
scribe for this project.
[INAUDIBLE]
So the first thing
we started with
is contextual inquiry using
the HAAT model so just
a quick review of what
the HAAT model is.
We are looking at the
human activity assistive
technology and then the
context, and then trying
to get all the
aspect of the problem
that we're trying to solve.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about
is Paul, our client.
He has been an amputee
for the past 30 years.
He worked in IT before, but
for the past two or three years
he had a really
severe hip problem.
He couldn't really get around,
and he had to stay home a lot.
And he had a surgery
in June, so he's
able to walk again but
with reduced arm strength.
So that means he wouldn't be
able to walk a long distance.
He wouldn't be able to
carry really heavy things.
And this is the AT he uses.
It's custom-made
forearm crutches.
It's really expensive, and
it's customized to Paul.
And so some of the
activities that he
wanted us to do a project on
are self-standing crutches,
a mechanism to pull
a suitcase, something
to carry a slice
of pizza, something
to carry a cup of coffee,
a self-standing umbrella,
so he doesn't get
wet in the rain.
So all of these activities
just kind of show
that Paul really just wants
to do things that people do
and that he really wants to get
out there again after this hip
problem isn't bothering him.
And we narrowed it
down to this problem;
this is a quote by
Paul, "it would be nice
if I can bring my way
of a cup of coffee.
Wouldn't that be nice?"
And we think, yeah, so
this is the problem we
that ended up pursuing.
And then we dove into the
context of this problem more.
So looking at it from
a few perspectives,
so culturally he doesn't
want to use a wheelchair.
Like I said, he had
a hip problem before,
so he had to be on
an electric scooter,
and he actually
didn't like that all.
He wants to use crutches.
He wants to be able to stand.
But because of the
nature of his injury,
he couldn't use prosthetics,
so he had to use crutches.
And socially his wife helps
him with many activities,
including bringing him coffee.
But his wife does have
work, so he needs to do this
by himself when he's at home.
And physically he just wants
to do this in his apartment.
When he brews a cup of
coffee in the morning.
He wants to be able to
carry it to the living room,
something like simple like that.
And looking at it one
statement, so this
is our problem
statement-- a design,
a mechanism, that help him carry
a cup of coffee around his home
without spilling,
and such that he
doesn't have to grab onto it.
And this is the way he
carries it right now.
It's kind of a grip
and then while trying
to use crutches at the same
time, so you can imagine,
it's really tough.
And we kind of break it down
to two main problems, which
is how do we do it hands-free,
so he doesn't have to hold it,
and how do we do no-spill,
so he doesn't spill coffee
on his hands.
And I'll let Lexi talk
about the success metrics.
LEXI DIEN: So right
now, basically, Paul
can carry a cup of coffee
around with that claw grip,
and he can only fill
it about a third
full if he doesn't want to
spill it all over his hands
or on the floor.
We'd like to make that a
larger amount of coffee,
and we'd like to make sure
that it isn't spilled.
So for a livable goal we
decided that maybe the coffee
would be 2/3 full and
he could not spill it.
And then as an
ambitious goal, we
would say 3/4 full
and also no spill.
Some other additional
things we talked about
were making it easy to
remove from his crutch
or from whatever it is;
the technology is just
easy to use and take away.
And so we said 20 seconds for
a livable and then 10 seconds
preferably.
We want it to be
as quick possible.
We also decided that
we wanted to take
Paul's perspective into this.
I think that's very important.
We wanted, especially,
him to rate
it, and we're hoping ambitiously
to get an 8 out of 10.
More livably, we
think a 6 out of 10
will be something
that we'd accept,
but we really want to get as
high as possible on his rating.
And the last thing we
wanted to make sure
is that we actually are
able to use it with a mug.
He uses his own mugs, and wants
to be able to use his own mugs.
So we want to make sure that
it works for at least that mug,
and preferably it works
for a lot of his mugs
or all of his mugs.
So we're going to show you
the video that we put together
that gives you a little bit
more background into Paul.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know, it would be
just nice if I could
bring my wife cup of coffee.
I mean, wouldn't that be nice?
My name's Paul [? Nershimski. ?]
I'm 62 years old.
I've been disabled
since I was 24.
-Paul uses forearm crutches
because his imputation
doesn't allow for a prosthetic.
Despite the fact that his
forearm crutches don't really
let him carry things while
he's walking, for Paul,
the most important
thing is to be
able to move around
and go places.
-And one the big
dreams of my life
has been to be able to
carry around a coffee
cup around the house
like a normal human
being with burning my
fingers and ruining the rug.
-What really drew me to Paul
was just the very simple nature
of what he wanted, something
that you and I take
for granted, just the ability
to transport food and even just
a cup of coffee from his
crutches to his living room
without spilling it
all over his floor.
-Cup full of water,
not far from the brim,
I would have to carry it like
that, with my hand wrapped
around the crutch handle.
And maybe you can realized
that would be a horror show.
-He wants to carry
a cup of coffee
around without burning himself,
and that's very, very different
from other people, other
clients, had in mind.
But this project's
very mechanical.
It' very simple, yet a
really challenging problem.
-That may seem like not
much to most people,
but it's huge to me.
-There are many, many
ideas floating around,
but one of them is a
gyroscope, something
that would with the
gyroscopic motion
that can keep the coffee level
while he's with his crutches.
And this is one of
the designs that we
saw online that kind of
resembles what we want to have.
It's basically a cup
holder that allows
motion, that allows it to stay
level when there is motion.
-There's a kind of silicon cover
that goes over the coffee mug,
and if it gets a good seal, then
it works really, really well.
-Silicone cover does
wonders-- nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
-So you have water in there?
-Yeah, it's pretty full.
-Wow, that's great.
-That really works.
I mean, that's full.
I try no to over think things,
get like a real simple thing
that I couldn't do.
And you're making it so I'm
going to be able to do it.
[END PLAYBACK]
LEXI DIEN: So, as
you saw in the video,
we've been trying out a
lot of different prototypes
with Paul, mainly things
that we found online,
some things like this on-stage
cup holder, which is basically
a cup holder that can
statically be just clicked
on to his crutch, and it
doesn't help tipping at all,
so if it was an open cup,
it would just pour out.
But it's something that
helps the hands-free aspect.
And something like the
water bottle holder
would also do this maybe,
except for it might not
fit a mug very well.
So right now we're looking
into some snap-on clamps,
like this one.
It would just be easy to
snap on and off of his crutch
so that he could take
it off and on the crutch
very easily and very quickly.
So I'm going to
pass these around
for people to look at it.
Some ideas for the
no-spill solution-- as you
saw, we were thinking
gyroscope maybe.
It turns out that that's a
little bit more complicated
than we thought it would be.
It's a little touchy.
So we're trying to look a
little bit in a different way.
The second thing we
did was the CoverFlex,
which we showed in the video.
It takes a little bit of time
to put on and off though,
so we were looking into some
other ways, which one of them
is this suction cover.
So this is a mug, very easy.
I'm going to pour
some water into it
and then put one of these
section covers on top of it,
and no water will spill out.
So we're hoping that this will
be able to work for his mugs
as well, and work on
that a little bit.
Another thing that we're looking
into, which is coming in today,
is this Spill-Not, which is
a device that's specifically
made to counteract movement.
When you place a mug
on it, basically, that
would make it so that it
wouldn't spill hopefully.
So we're looking into
that a little bit more.
BRADY ENSTAD: So at
our client meaning
for the first
prototype, like I said,
we showed Paul the
on-stage microphone clip,
and we showed him the
CoverFlex silicon cover,
and we left those with
him this past week,
and we're going to go back
on Wednesday after class
and get is feedback on those.
He was actually more
excited because we told him
that the Spill-Not was coming.
He was more excited about
that than anything else.
But the CoverFlex, as
you saw in the video,
actually worked
really, really well.
The only difficulty with
it is that once you have it
on and take it off,
like if there's
been any spillage at all,
it's a little difficult
to get it back on again,
which is why we decided to go
with these suction covers.
The only problem with those is
they might not fit his mugs.
So there's a
possibility that we'll
have to do a little bit
more shopping around
to find larger covers that
will probably fit his mugs.
That's honestly the biggest
problem is his mugs are huge.
So coffee addict, or
something, but yeah,
like I said he's super, duper
excited about the Spill-Not.
And honestly one of
our biggest visions
for what will end
up happening is
that we'll be able to
incorporate the Spill-Not
with a quick on-and-off
clamp, like the one that's
going around.
Like I said, the clamp, it
works really well on-stage,
but it doesn't really
prevent spilling,
and it's pretty slow because
it's a screw-on/screw-off type
mechanism, as opposed
to just a quick clamp.
He liked the CoverFlex,
but if there's
something that's easier,
like those suction covers,
then he would prefer that.
So for future work,
as I said, we're
going to be testing more
off-the-shell prototypes,
different suction
mug covers maybe.
The bike cup holder,
we haven't entirely
abandoned that idea yet either.
And then obviously,
the Spill-Not
is what we're most
excited about.
We're going to go get
feedback from Paul.
And if he has some
feedback for us
that we can't meet with any
off-the-shelf prototypes,
then we're just going
to do some customization
for his final prototype.
PROFESSOR: So first
of all, you guys
have scoped this really well, in
the sense that this is a really
well-defined problem that
you've worked out with Paul.
And it seems like you're
finding a lot of pieces
to the solution that are already
out there, that maybe you
can combine to make something
that's really good for him.
So I would encourage you, or
have you thought about-- let
me phrase this as a question.
Have you thought about
the sustainability
of your solution?
So these cover flex things,
for example, how do they fail?
And how will things break?
And what is going
to have to replace?
And sort of what is
the lifetime of what
you're building for him?
BRADY ENSTAD: So the great
thing about the CoverFlex
is that it's actually
oven and dishwasher safe.
So presumably, it's got a
relatively long life cycle,
and we're thinking, honestly,
on the order of, hopefully,
years because it is oven
and dishwasher safe,
unless he somehow super-duper
heats it beyond what it's rated
for, which I don't
really know how you'd
do that because it's oven safe.
And as far as the clamp, the
hands-free solution goes,
frankly it's a purely
mechanical systems.
So unless he finds
some way to snap off
the clamp, which it could
happen, don't get me wrong,
but the great thing about
these components that we found
is that they're actually
relatively inexpensive.
And so the idea we have
is that after the class
is over we would leave him
with these part numbers.
Because he has a computer
at home-- he's tech savvy.
He used to work in IT-- so
if something were to break,
he could just purchased
himself another one,
assuming that there's not a
great deal of customization
that goes into it.
And we don't actually know the
scope of customization that's
going to have to go into it
just yet because, as I said,
what we're most excited
about is the Spill-Not,
and we're not really
sure how that's
going to be incorporated
with the clamp just yet.
PROFESSOR 2: So I would
just kind of encourage
as you're thinking about
the failure modes, not just
the individual failure
modes, but kind
of the cross-coupled
failure modes--
as I was looking at the
seal, one of the ways
that you release the seal is
by kind of flipping that edge,
so you want to be careful
that that edge isn't actually
going to be affected by
whatever your mechanism is
for holding it.
So think about the
kind of the coupling
that you get between
your solutions,
and not just the independent
issues that you have with them.
One of the questions that
I had for you was regarding
your performance metrics,
how you selected those on/off
times, and how that
related to his function
versus the mechanical
structure itself?
And kind of from looking
at some of your video,
I'm wondering--
I couldn't really
tell if he had any additional
tremors or other issues
as well that might
affect his function that
might affect that timing.
So if you could just talk on
that generation of timing?
BRADY ENSTAD: Yeah, sure, so
honestly, we just asked Paul.
We said, Paul, how quickly do
you want this thing be put on
and be taken off?
And he said, well,
relatively quickly,
and he wouldn't give
us a solid number.
So we were just
like, OK, you know,
20 seconds is a little long.
10 seconds seems like
a reasonable time.
The great thing about Paul
is the only disability
that he has is the fact
that his leg is amputated.
So doesn't have any
tremors or anything
else, any other
sort of disability.
So I mean, as we talked
about actually in lecture
earlier today, it's
possible as he gets older,
those hands might start
shaking and that sort of thing.
But that's actually why
we're excited about the clamp
is because there's less
precision involved.
It's just a pretty
simple snapping motion.
So as far as like
generating those numbers,
it was just basically a
kind of a general feeling
we got from Paul, and
we went with, well,
what do you think
about these numbers?
And the great thing
about Paul is also
one of the worst things
he's incredibly laid back,
so he wasn't particularly
zealous about giving
us had numbers.
So he was pretty
willing to along
with anything that we suggested.
PROFESSOR 2: What are ways that
you think that you guys might
be able to validate those
numbers a little bit more
as you keep going
and looking at some
of these different designs?
BRADY ENSTAD: Sure, so if
you take a look at the clamp,
between positioning
it and snapping it,
I think you're probably looking
at realistically probably
less than five seconds.
It's not real picky about
where you put it on the crutch.
So obviously, we're
just going to keep
adjusting those
numbers as what's
realistic becomes more apparent.
Like I said, we don't
really know the degree
of customization we're going to
have to go to yet, especially
if we're going to
incorporate the Spill-Not.
So once we get that and we do
a little bit more prototyping,
I'd be able to give you
more solid answer for that.
But as of right now,
we don't really know.
PROFESSOR 3: I am a
coffee aficionado,
and I just am OCD about
the cup that I have.
I have two or three
mugs that I just love.
I can press the Keurig twice,
and it fills it up just right.
So I get that.
But I'm wondering,
have you talked
with this gentleman about
his ability or willingness
to negotiate?
To me, one of the
obvious solutions
would be to have-- because
he has good hand function,
presumably-- is to
fill up a thermos mug
and have a simple clip that
you can put on his foreleg
crutches, walk to a
table, and pour the coffee
into his delightful cup.
BRADY ENSTAD: So that's actually
one of the very first thoughts
that we had, and we
asked Paul about that.
And his reply honestly
surprised us a little bit.
He's not honestly
concerned about carrying
the cup of coffee
so much for himself,
as it is that he wants
to help his wife out.
Because while he was stuck in
the wheelchair, he was really,
really reliant on
her, and so he wants
to be able to carry a cup
of coffee for his wife.
And his whole
thing about that is
that I want to be able
to carry it in the mug
and just give it
to her, and I don't
want have to pour it out at the
table or anything like that.
PROFESSOR 4: One or two quick
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: So his Paul willing to
have something on his crutches,
or is that [INAUDIBLE],
like the [INAUDIBLE]?
BRADY ENSTAD: So that's why we
were talking about quick on/off
times, and the answer to
that is, no, not really.
He's OK with using it for
the short period of time
that it takes to transport
the cup of coffee.
But once he gets
to the couch, he
wants to be able to take
it off because the way
that he stores his crutches
when he's sitting down,
is he puts them on the floor.
And so if there's
anything attached to them
that might possibly get in
the way was his concerned.
So the quicker on/off
time, the better.
PROFESSOR 4: [INAUDIBLE]
last question,
then we can have Team Margaret
also begin to set up as well.
PROFESSOR 3: The other
quick thing I wanted to ask
is, have you consulted
an occupational therapist
at all, someone who deals
with these kinds of approaches
on a daily basis?
There might be some other simple
solution that-- or maybe not so
simple solution,
but an established
solution that someone
has already dealt with.
Because obviously, amputation
and this kind of injury
is fairly common and ubiquitous.
BRADY ENSTAD: And the answer
to that is, no, we haven't.
But that sounds like
a really great idea,
so we'll look into that.
PROFESSOR 4: Thank you.
BRADY ENSTAD: Thanks.
TANYA TALKAR: So, hi, everyone.
We're Team Margaret.
I'm Tanya.
LAURA D'AQUILA: I'm Laura.
TANYA TALKAR: And
Beth his third member,
but she's unable to get make
it to the presentation today.
So this is the team.
I think we might have shown
you this picture last week,
but this is
Margaret, our client.
Interesting story
about this picture--
she was actually the
one who suggested
that we take a selfie.
So she's a great person.
So a little bit about
her as a person.
She is an artist, so she loves
to paint, loves to make arts
and crafts.
Her room is filled
with a bunch of crafts.
She's also an advocate, so
she's on the Safety Council
for The Boston Home,
which means that she's
talking a lot with residents
to make sure that they are
comfortable with their
position at The Boston Home
and everything that's going on.
And Laura will talk a little
bit about The Boston Home.
She's also a friend.
She FaceTimes a lot on her
iPad with friends and family,
And she's an immensely
helpful mentor,
not only to us, but also
all of the other residents
of the Boston Home.
So about her
disability-- she was
diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis,
and she decided on her own
to live at The Boston Home.
So she has been
at The Boston Home
for about eight years, gotten
during admission process.
She gets around on a
motorized wheelchair.
All of the resonance
have wheelchairs,
and she's relatively
independent.
She has some fatigue in terms
of trying to sign documents,
or after using her iPad for a
while, she will get fatigued,
and her fingers will drag.
But she is still
relatively independent.
And she was a social
worker before she
came to The Boston
Home, which means
that all of her thoughts and
actions are really altruistic.
She's always thinking
about other people.
LAURA D'AQUILA:
So this over here
is a picture of The Boston Home.
It's located in
Dorchester, Massachusetts.
And Beth, Tanya, and I
go visit it every Friday
to meet with Margaret,
other residents, and staff
members of the home.
To tell you a little
bit more about the home,
it was founded in 1881
as a long-term care
center for adults with
multiple sclerosis
and other progressive
neurodegenerative diseases.
The average resident in The
Boston Home is 58 years old,
and The Boston Home
places great emphasis
on independence of residents.
So we'll see later
on that there's
a lot of assistive
technology that does
exist within The Boston Home.
There's 96 residents in the
home and approximately 200 staff
members.
And it's a really
nice place to live.
They have activities,
meetings, other social events,
and it's known nationally for
providing exceptional care
to residents.
And this over here is a picture
of Don, one of our panelists.
He's done a lot of
great work in the home
for making sure that
residents do have access
to assistive technology.
For example, he mounts iPads
on the motorized wheelchairs
of residents.
He also has a 3D
printer that he's
used to design pieces
of assistive technology.
TANYA TALKAR: So
specifically, the activity
that we've been working
with for the past month has
been the nurse call system
or the call light system.
And so what this is,
is that residents,
if they're in their room, can
press a button-- we'll show it
in a bit-- to call a
nurse and call and aide
to come and help
them in their room.
So there's a wired-in
call light system.
It's a button that it has
been wired to the wall,
and nurses are currently
trained to place this button
in the middle of bed.
Many times though,
it's forgotten about.
So it's either not placed
in the middle of the better,
or it's placed in
an unreachable spot.
So Margaret sometimes
has to come up to a table
and has to either
pull on the wire
or pull on sheets to
try and get the button.
And there's also just no
way of using the system
if the resident is
outside the home.
So.
For example, there was a
resident who had gone outside,
got stuck in a ditch, and
his wheelchair tipped over,
and he was unable to call
The Boston Home to let them
know that this has happened.
So they had to have someone
who was passing by tell them
that that happened.
So this is the
call light system.
The button is pretty
easy to press.
It's just like a simple press.
But, again, it's placed in
this kind of inconvenient spot,
where Margaret can't reach.
She doesn't have
much of a reach,
so she can't reach up to
press the button if need be.
And so in addition to that,
there's some other issues.
Only one nurse is allowed to
answer the calls at any time.
Her name's Angela.
And so she sit at
the front desk,
and this takes a
long time if there
are multiple
residents calling in
or if she has gone from
the desk and has to address
another resident's issues.
So an aide also has to come in
to turn off the call system,
otherwise it keeps
on beeping, and that
is quite annoying for both
the resident and the nurse.
Many times, if there are
two rooms within a suite,
as it is with Margaret,
so enter a door
and there are two rooms there,
sometimes the wrong room
is answered, so you'll have the
nurse call into the other room.
And since this is
a speaker system,
if the resident is unable
to speak really loudly,
or, in Margaret's case, she once
pulling out a chest of drawers
and it fell on her.
So she was unable to both
reach the call light system.
And if she had,
she wouldn't have
been able to speak loud enough
for the nurse to hear her.
And actually, to add
to that, so that's
the reason why we're
planning on using
an iPad for this solution.
So we're planning on
creating application,
because Margaret always
has her iPod with her,
such that she can just
press a couple of buttons
and be able to talk with
the nurses directly.
LAURA D'AQUILA: So to talk more
about assistive technology,
both what Margaret
herself uses and what
other residents at
The Boston Home use,
Margaret, along with
many other residents,
uses a motorized
wheelchair to get around.
And Margaret is very tech savvy.
She owns both an
iPad and an iPhone,
which she always has with her.
And she owns a special
stylus so that she's actually
able to use her iPad and
reach all ends of the screen.
And they've come in handy
in emergency situations.
Tanya mentioned the time when
the drawer fell on Margaret
and she was unable to reach
the existing call light system
button.
But fortunately, because
she had her iPhone,
she was able to call
for help that way.
And the Tanya had mentioned
that Margaret is an artist,
and she's able to
use a mouthpiece
to hold her paintbrush,
and that's something
that Don had designed for her.
And along with other
residents in the home,
Margaret has the call light
system button in her bedroom
and also in the bathroom.
So thanks to much of Don's work,
The Boston Home is very open
to assistive
technology, and it's
very prevalent
within the home now.
For example, there exists a
cyber cafe, where resonance
are able to use computers, and
both the keyboards and mice
within the cyber cafe are
accessible to the needs
of the residents with
their limited arm mobility.
And there are also speech
therapists and occupational
therapists on site, and these
individuals use technology,
such as iPads, in
order to assess
the progress of the residents.
And Don has added many
features to wheelchairs
throughout his time
their too, accommodating
the different needs
of the residents.
TANYA TALKAR: So to assess
how this application is going
to work for Margaret and for the
residents, because her vision
is that at the
end of this, we'll
be able to have all 35
residents who are using iPads
also use the system.
We have a couple
of success metrics.
They're mostly qualitative.
So, one, we just
want to make sure
that the correct iPad is
being called and answered
and that the correct
resident is getting aid.
We will also want to
time the amount of time
that it takes for a
task to be completed.
So suppose Margaret
needs a refill of water,
so the nurse will come in
with the call light system,
get the request, and then
go back to get the water.
versus if we have this on the
iPad application, how much time
that'll take.
And then just success overall--
does this application actually
integrate into the current
system with the nurses?
Will the nurses actually
end up using the system?
Will the residents actually end
up using the system as well?
LAURA D'AQUILA: So
a few weeks ago we
started discussing with
Margaret potential solutions
to this problem.
Tanya had mentioned that we're
going to be using an iPad.
We work with Margaret to get
her input and her feedback
to actually develop some
early sketches of what
her end of this app looked like.
And then within
the next week, we
developed this into a
low fidelity iOS app,
which I'll walk through now.
So this is the home
screen of the app
that Margaret is going
to have access to.
It has two large
by things that are
color-coded red and black, for
urgent and non-urgent requests.
And should Margaret
press Non-Urgent Request,
she's taken to the
next screen, which
has six potentially customizable
buttons for a common requests
that Margaret may
have for the nurse.
For example, if she
needs a cup of water
or if she wants a nurse
to come to a room,
if she wants to be able to
video conference with a nurse,
these are all buttons
that are easily
accessible for her to press.
And similarly, if Margaret
presses the Urgent button,
she's taken directly into
a video call with a nurse.
And at the bottom, there is
a Cancel Call button for her
to cancel in the event
that she inadvertently
pressed the button.
TANYA TALKAR: So
amazingly enough,
right after we transferred
this application to her iPad,
she immediately
went off to go talk
to some of the other residents
about the application, which
is great.
And so some of the feedback
that she came up with
was that she wanted to make
sure that the buttons were
large enough, in case residents
end up having some fatigue
and their fingers start
dragging on the iPad.
So she uses a stylus, but
not all of the residents do.
So we just make sure that we
have larger buttons for this.
She also wanted to make
sure that there was
an option to type in messages.
So suppose any of the
requests that a resident
has isn't on the screen
with six buttons,
that they will be able to
type in their own customized
request.
She also wants to make
sure that she's always
talking with the nurse
through a video call
because sometimes her
message or what she wants
isn't conveyed through text.
And something that all of the
residents said they wanted
was that the application
be voice-activated
because not all of
them are able to press
the buttons at every
time, and that they'll
be able to go forward
with this if they
can't speak super well either.
LAURA D'AQUILA: So in
addition to Margaret,
because of the nature of the
system that we're building,
we actually have an
additional client,
and that's the nurse on
the other end of the system
that Margaret's trying to reach.
So we had mentioned all
of these nice features
that we want the app to have,
for example, video chat.
And none of this stuff is
feasible with the existing
call light system that exists
already within the home.
So because of that, we're
hoping to bypass the existing
system altogether and have
the nurse on the other end
have an iPad or
a computer screen
as well with an instance
of this app running
so that she can receive
the requests from Margaret
on this app.
So because of this, we've
had to speak with and work
with Angela, who,
as Tanya mentioned,
is the nurse on the first floor,
which is Margaret's floor, so
that we can make sure that
we can accommodate her needs.
In addition to Margaret's
needs in terms of what
this application should have.
And we've also worked
with Don to make sure
that this app is feasible to
be adopted within the nurse's
station.
And within the next
few weeks, we're
also going to work on speaking
with other management level
people within The
Boston Home to make sure
that we're able to get
their go-to as well.
And one potential thing
that we're still discussing
is how to acquire a potential
iPad that the nurse would
need at her station.
So we're looking into whether
this is something The Boston
Home would purchase, or
whether it's something
that we may need to get
with our own team budget.
So in terms of the timeline, we
spent the first month speaking
with Margaret, getting
to know her, her needs,
and what she's looking for
in a potential solution.
And then in October,
we were able to assess
in greater detail
the feasibility
of an iPad-based
solution on both ends.
We worked with
Margaret and Angela.
We developed a low fidelity
prototypes for Margaret
and tested this out
and received feedback.
And then in November,
our plans include
developing a low fidelity
prototypes for Angela,
for the nurses' side of
the nurse call system.
We hope to receive
feedback from that
and iterate through
those prototypes as well.
We also want to work on the
back end of actually sending
requests from Margaret's
iPad to the nurses' iPads.
And we want to get video
conferencing set up
the week after that.
And then finally, hopefully
by the end of November
or beginning of
December, we'll have
an app that's able to
be used within the home
by not only Margaret, but
potentially other residents
in the home as well, and we can
continue to test it out and get
feedback from them.
TANYA TALKAR: So a
little bit about how
the logistics for this
project go-- our meetings are
pretty conversational.
They're less like an
interview, and more
just us talking with
Margaret, Angela, Don.
So Laura is mostly in charge
of the videos and pictures,
and then Beth and I are the
ones who are taking notes,
asking the questions.
And we meet before the meetings
to go over speaking notes
and go over an agenda
of what exactly
we want to be accomplished
during the meeting.
As for division of work for the
application itself, all of us
are new to iOS development.
So we're learning
all of this together.
We're planning on mostly
working on the application
as a team, all three
of us together.
And then for other things,
Beth and Laura mainly
worked on the video, and I was
mostly in charge of the report
and the presentation for
the mid-semester panels.
LAURA D'AQUILA: So
to conclude, we're
very excited to be working
on this project with Margaret
this semester.
It's been a lot of fun so
far, and it's exciting to us
that this is something
that could potentially not
only benefit Margaret,
but could also
benefit many other residents
of The Boston Home,
should this be more
universally adopted.
PROFESSOR 2: So
one of the things
that you guys mentioned
at the beginning,
as you were talking
about the call system,
was some of the regulations
that are in place at the home.
Can you talk about how
your system actually
can map to some of
those regulations,
and if they have to change in
any way to use your system?
TANYA TALKAR: So that was
actually one of the things
that we are considering when we
were thinking about whether we
wanted to interface with the
current call light system,
or whether we would create
this separate iPad application.
And that's also one
of things we need
to talk with for administration.
We believe that due to this
being a separate application,
we shouldn't need to
have the nurses go in
and turn off anything
on the iPad, which
is what they need to currently
do with the call light system.
And that's something that
the company themselves
had come up with as
a regulation, that it
would have to be turned
off by a nurse aide.
But for this, because it's the
resident who's in charge of it,
and they'll be video
calling with the nurse,
we believe that it
shouldn't be a problem.
PROFESSOR 2: So I guess
my question is, how does
that regulation actually map?
So not the fact that
the system requires it,
but what is the kind of
the purpose of having
that regulation
requirement, and is
it something that you guys
should be matching or not
matching?
It's an open question.
Is there a benefit to having
the nurse specifically
go there and turn
off, and did they
design that into the
system not because it
was needed for the
system, but because it
was important for the task?
TANYA TALKAR: So we've
asked everyone about that.
They haven't really
been able to come up
with an answer for that.
Margaret herself kind
of finds it intrusive
that you have to come in and
turn off the light manually,
instead of her just being
able to turn it off.
So, yeah, we're not
really completely sure
why that is there.
We just know that it's a
regulation on the company's
part.
PROFESSOR 3: Well, it's clearly
a Department of Public Health
regulation, and it evolved out
of abuse and neglect issues,
where you could
respond to a resident
or just repeatedly shut
their call request off,
without really
addressing a need.
But skirting DPH--
sometimes you sort of
have to play the
game a little bit.
So if it's an experimental
or a redundant system,
it may not have to
match their regulations
as long as the primary one meets
those specific requirements
of having someone go
to attend to them.
But I am curious how you honed
in on that specific approach
that you've taken of using the
iPad and using that simple GUI,
versus some of the ideas
I had pitched initially.
TANYA TALKAR: So I think
I was mostly through just
talking to Margaret.
And her approach to this was
that if she was in a situation
where she wasn't able to
reach the call light system,
her immediate thought
would be to use her iPhone
and call The Boston
Home and try and reach
the nurses through that.
And so we felt that that would
be a little easier to interface
in that way, in terms of
she always has her iPad
or her iPhone with her.
And so suppose there were
connectivity issues in terms
of like we weren't unable
to reach the-- suppose
there was like a Bluetooth that
was attached to the call light
system, if that connectivity
wasn't established and wasn't
stable, then that
would be an issue,
as opposed to having
Wi-Fi, which I think
would be more reliable
within the home and slightly
outside of the home as well.
PROFESSOR 3: Good.
PROFESSOR 1: What I would ask is
how much function does Margaret
herself actually have?
It's clear that you're
trying to broaden
this other members of The
Boston Home, which is great,
but what can Margaret
herself do with an iPad app,
and have you measured
that, or have you observed
her use of the prototype?
LAURA D'AQUILA: So Margaret
has limited use of her arms,
and it varies depending
on how tired she is.
So when she's
particularly fatigued,
it's even harder for her
to reach the full screen
coverage of the iPad.
But because of the fact that
she has a stylus that definitely
helps, but that's also
part of the reason
why we had looked into
adding the large buttons
so that it's more feasible for
Margaret and other residents
to be able to use all of these
functionalities of the app.
But, yeah, she can move her
arms a little bit, but not very
much.
Tanya had mentioned that on
the first day we met with her,
we needed her to sign a
contract for our team contract,
and it was clearly
a struggle for her
to be able to move her
arms to sign the document.
When she paints, she
uses a mouthpiece
so that she can do it that way.
So I'd say that her arm
movement is pretty limited,
but because of the stylus,
she's able to at least get
by with the iPad.
PROFESSOR 2: We can probably
take another one or two
questions if anyone
has comments.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
You talked about there was that
situation when someone fell
over and was stuck in a ditch.
How could they access this
application in the iPad?
Are you considering [INAUDIBLE]?
LAURA D'AQUILA: Right,
so maybe depending
on the exact situation,
they personally may not
be able to use this app.
But in the event
that maybe there's
another resident
who's also outside,
it may be a little bit easier
for that second resident
to call for help while they're
still outside, as opposed
to having to go
into the building
to alert the nurses
of what had happened.
But, yeah, in the
event that it's
just one person outside and
depending on the situation,
if they're not able to use
the iPad, like if it fell
or something, then I guess
it wouldn't help them.
But it's more so
in the situation
where there's multiple people.
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was interesting
that you had identified the
nurses as your second client.
It's very smart
of you to do that.
How many signals are they being
bombarded by on an average day,
and how is that going to
affect how you would get
their attention [INAUDIBLE]?
TANYA TALKAR: So
Angela currently just
has the nurse call system plus
a computer set up at the desk.
And then, of course,
if there any nurses
who are coming up
to her to talk,
that will be a
distraction as well.
So that was one of
the primary things
that we wanted to address with
her when we talked to her.
So that's why we're wondering,
should it be on the computer,
or should it be on
a separate iPad?
And she did tell us that
with all the signals
that she's getting, if
it was on the computer,
she would not be looking at it
because you'll be most probably
browsing other applications,
if it's email or whatever.
And then with the
call light system,
that is also something that
beeps whenever someone calls
in, so she will address that.
But if there is an
iPad just mounted
like right in the
middle there, she'll
be able to see that as a
notification coming in.
And she said that
because of where
she is sitting at the desk,
then she'll be able to see that.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question.
I noticed I didn't hear
anything about what
was the client [INAUDIBLE]
nurse [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of the [? hybrid ?]
liability of this application.
Have you guys considered
putting that into your metric
as well for success?
Like what does
she expect to work
90% of the time,
80% of the time?
And also, what [INAUDIBLE]?
You know, complicated
systems are complicated
for a reason Maybe that's
something-- like have you
guys had a conversation
with the client about this?
LAURA D'AQUILA: We
haven't had a conversation
about a specific number,
but one of the benefits
to the fact that we have
this iPad system on top
of the existing system is that
in the event that Wi-Fi goes
out or something like
that in the home,
and the iPad app
that isn't working,
then Margaret does
have the ability
to simply use the system
that's in place, which I think
is known to at least go through
to the nurse pretty reliably,
if not receive a
response all the time.
PROFESSOR 2: All right, let's
have Team [? Aaron ?] come up.
PHILIP: So hello, everyone.
We're Team Kate.
My name is Philip [INAUDIBLE].
And my teammates here are--
JENNY: Jenny.
RAQUEL: Hi, I'm Raquel.
[? PHILIP: So ?] today we're
just going to talk about
the progress that we've made
over the course of the last few
weeks in our project with Kate.
Let me quickly introduce
who our client is.
Over the last few weeks,
we've been talking about Kate.
She's our client, and she works
at the Cambridge Disabilities
Commission.
She has profound hearing loss,
and wears a cochlear implant.
We also have this really short
video, about two minutes long,
in which talks about herself
and a little bit more
about the hearing
impairment that she has.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Without my cochlear implants,
I have no residual hearing
at all, so that would
be considered profound.
With my cochlear implants, I
have a mild to moderate hearing
loss.
But obviously, I do really
well with my implants.
You through in any
background noise,
and it's just you
can forget about it.
In this kind of
setting I do really
well with my cochlear implants.
So I was born with a
very mild hearing loss.
I just had like preferential
seating in school.
And it became profound
or rapidly progressive
when I was 13.
It went from mild to moderate
to severe and then to profound.
I got my first cochlear
implant my left side in 1999.
I had my right side done in
2008, so nine years later.
It is not a quick fix.
So when it was first
turned on, everything,
like my brother's would
like stomp their feet,
and it would sound like someone
was ringing little bells.
It was weird.
And I couldn't
understand any speech,
but I had to force myself
to turn my hearing aid off
on the right side.
And I was home from college
for six or seven weeks.
and I did all these listening
exercises with my family.
We made it a game.
Like my mom would
take children's books.
And at first, she
would read them aloud,
and I would follow along,
trying to place what
I was hearing with the words.
And then I would
graduate from that,
and I wasn't allowed to
follow along-- to read along.
and I was trying to
follow the story,
just basically
training my brain.
So my brain was receiving the
signal in a slightly new way.
And so I basically had
to retrain my brain
how to take that signal and
interpret it into usable sound.
I mean, I can't
tell you how much
it has changed my life though.
Like I used to
walk around college
with a little whiteboard, and
people would write notes to me.
It has completely changed
my life-- completely.
So for me.
It was so worth it.
[END PLAYBACK]
PHILIP: So we've already
seen from the video
that Katie uses
cochlear implants,
and on this I would
just like to mention
that a lot of people who
have hearing impediments
still have functional nerve
ending, the auditory nerves.
The main problem is
just that the part
of the ear that is
responsible for transmitting
sound to an electric
signals that are translated
by the brain aren't functional.
So it is that part of the
ear that the cochlear implant
tries to fix.
So the cochlear
implant basically
provides a new channel
through which sound
signals can be transmitted
to electrical signals
for the brain to interpret.
RAQUEL: So now we can get
into a little bit of what
our goals is a Team Kate.
So our major goal here is
to create cochlear implant
attachments, so whether it's
covers or clip-on add-ons
to her cochlear implant
to kind of hit on three
particular sub-goals in this.
So the first is to provide
some water resistance
to her implant.
So currently, it
isn't water resistant,
and she doesn't have a cover
that she uses for that.
So to give some
context for that desire
is that she, just
like any of us,
often finds ourselves
in the rain.
It seems like it's a
great day to begin with,
and by the end of
day, it's pouring.
So for Kate that means
walking around with her hands
like this, covering
her implants,
or taking off her
implants entirely,
and that's not ideal because
she can no longer hear.
A second goal for
our implant covers
are to provide some
sort of sound blocking.
So Kate has issues in
noisy environments.
And what I mean by this is
like in a lobby or a restaurant
where there's just lots of
background noise going on,
she has problems
distinguishing sounds
that are coming from behind
her from sounds that are
coming from in front of her.
So she's having a
conversation with somebody.
It's hard to actually
comprehend what
they're saying when there's
lots of noise from behind.
And currently, her implant
just has a single microphone
so there's no kind of
sound directionality
capability to it.
And so an idea for
this is just provide
some sort of physical barrier
to basically block sound
from behind her.
The third thing here
is attachedness.
So she has a problem with
her cochlear implants
just falling off all the
time for different reasons.
But one goal for us is
to try to just provide
something that gives it a
little bit more stability
so it just stays
on her head more.
So the context of
that one in particular
is really just any
place, any time.
The context for all
of these are kind
of just very portable
things that she
can use in her everyday life.
So we've come up with
a few success metrics.
We haven't formally
tested these yet.
But for the water
resistance goal
here, we'll be doing something
like a water bead test
for the material to make sure
that it's water resistant.
I guess I should say
that Kate has gotten
a demo of her cochlear
implant from the company that
makes her implants, so we can
do these water resistance tests
not on her actual implant.
But something like putting a
material, like a paper towel
or something that would show
wetness, around the implant,
putting on her cover,
spraying it, and looking
for signs of wetness and where
that wetness is coming in.
Sound blocking,
what we plan to do
is kind of a human subject
experiment with her.
So what we'll do is play noise,
a noisy environment behind her
from different audio clips.
and then have audio
clips in front of her
of speech or just
a conversation,
and try to kind of get
her subjective feedback,
and identify her threshold for
the volume of that conversation
in front of her, and
when she recognize that
with and without our different
sound-blocking devices.
And then attachedness--
so currently, we've
talked to Kate, and her
cochlear implants can fall out
up to 10 or 12 times a day,
and this isn't even necessarily
when she's being
particularly active.
So our goal is something
less than three time a day,
just something more reasonable
for her to deal with.
JENNY: So during our design
process, we talked to Kate,
and he's really, really
excited about this project
because it has been a problem
for her for a very long time,
and she showed us a bunch of
her existing solutions she has.
She had a head band that you
could hook the implants into,
and that would
keep them in place.
But it's very sporty.
It's a bright colored headband,
and it wasn't something
that she was pleased with.
And then she also had some
other kind of neoprene sleeves
that she could put
over her implants,
but these technologies were
all like pretty primitive,
and they only served to
solve one problem at once.
So through talking to her, we
identified a bunch of feature
that we wanted to
address, the three
features-- the water
resistance, sound blocking,
and attachedness-- and
we began prototyping.
So we each individually
sketched designs
so we could come up with many
ideas when we came together.
And as a team we chose
the few to prototype out.
And I'll show that
on the next slide.
But we used [INAUDIBLE], which
were two materials that we
discovered during lecture.
And then last week we presented
the prototypes to Kate
and did some informal testing.
And she was pretty
impressed them,
and that leads me to the next
slide of what we made so far.
So at the beginning,
we wanted to create
some sort of
all-on-one attachment
that would address all
three of the problems.
So on the left, you can see
it's like a unibody cover that
covers the entire
implant that also
provides a hood over the
microphone at the very top.
And then there's
also a little ear bud
that would help with
the attachments.
We decide not to go with that
because Kate wanted something
a little more modular,
something that she could just
have separate accessories
for each problem.
So when we prototyped
keeping this in mind,
we created separate covers.
So the left of the
top right photo
are covers for the
coil and the implant
itself, the device
with processor.
And then we also created
some sort of hood
that you can put right
over the microphone, which
it's a little hard to tell,
but the microphone right here.
So this hood, it
provides a small barrier
from the sound traveling from
behind to hit the microphone.
So we tried this out
and then also compared
it to these previously
existing devices.
They're called Ear Glasses,
and these help also
amplify sound that's
coming toward you.
And she was pretty
pleased with them.
And this was like
very informal, so we
plan to continue to prototype
and iterate our design
and then bring something
to show her on Thursday.
For the rest of
the semester, we're
looking to continue measuring
and testing out our success
metrics with the prototypes
that we're planning to build.
And then in November,
we hope to finalize
the design and the
materials that we're
going to use and then create
our final deliverable.
We're looking, like
materials wise,
we're keeping 3D
printing in mind
to actually create
the attachments.
But we haven't finalized it
yet, so that's just something
that we're looking at ahead.
And that concludes
our presentation.
Thank you, and we'll
take any questions.
PROFESSOR 1: First, that was
a really nice video explaining
her story with getting
the cochlear implants
and what kind of change
they've made in her life.
I'm curious about a couple of
other aspects of your client
that you alluded
to a little bit,
but I was wondering
how important they are.
First, how active or athletic is
she, and is it important to her
that these things be
really, really secure?
And second, how sensitive
is she to her appearance?
RAQUEL: So she's not
particularly active.
What she did tell
us is that she'll
starting pool therapy
soon for another condition
that she has that we
didn't talk about here,
but that she'll be using
the headband because it's
really important that they
don't fall off at all.
And she'll be in shallow
end and there will basically
be no water touching them.
But so for these it's really
just kind of daily life.
She works in an office.
She attends a lot of meetings.
So nothing too active.
She does ride her bike
every once in awhile,
and she has issues when
she puts on her helmet.
But again, she
uses that headband
that just really keeps it secure
on her head for those purposes.
And about her caring about what
she looks like, we actually
did ask her straight
up, how do you feel
about looking a little silly?
Is that OK?
And she said that's fine.
I think there's a fine line.
We don't want something
that's crazy sticking out.
But I think she's willing to
have a little bit of something
extra on her head.
She's even told us
that she prefers it
when people can see that she
has a cochlear implant, instead
of covering it up so that they
automatically know that she has
hearing loss so that they can
communicate better with her
from the beginning
of talking with them.
PROFESSOR 2: So I'm wondering
if you could talk more
about that design shape.
So you had the
kind of Ear Glasses
as something that was clearly
doing something similar that
provides that directionality.
And in your design, you showed
kind of two different methods
of a different shape that
was on that hood for how
you're doing that.
I'm wondering-- I know you
said you guys are still
kind of the middle of testing
and testing out of it.
How is that shape playing into
your kind of design decisions?
Are you are you specifically
designing shapes and testing
them, or is that more aesthetic?
JENNY: To be honest,
we haven't tested
that many shapes out yet.
I think that when we
do create a lot shapes,
we're going to look
at effectiveness
before aesthetics.
And we tried out
different sizes so far,
or we tried out
three different sizes
so far of the sound
blocking piece,
and definitely the
largest one actually
works the most effectively.
So we're going to find a
balance between portability
and effectiveness.
PROFESSOR 3: Any questions
from the audience here?
If we can have the
last team as well.
Jeffrey, [INAUDIBLE]
and get set up as well.
Any other questions or comments?
AUDIENCE: How are the ear
glasses supposed to stay on?
JENNY: As advertised,
they were supposed
to have some sort
of adhesive strip
that you can just pull
off and then stick on.
But they don't actually do that.
It didn't actually
come with that,
so they just sit on your ear.
But when we had her
try them on, we just
wanted her to try it on for
the shape of the ear glasses.
And she was really impressed
by how big of a difference
it made with her microphone.
RAQUEL: But these,
in particular,
won't stay on very well
for us, and they definitely
don't stay on with
her cochlear implant.
PROFESSOR 3: I assume
that magnets would
be a problem with the implants.
I don't know if you
address that specifically.
I'm just thinking of how
well devices click in place.
I'm just thinking quick
one in the extruder head
on the 3D printer, how would
you just get sort of lined up,
and it jumps into place.
And I like that
functionality, but I'm
wondering-- I'm
assuming-- that that would
be problem with the implants.
PHILIP: It's actually one of
the things that we considered.
But just like you
said, we weren't
sure about how adding
a magnet to the system
would affect the
way the outer part
of the implanted part of it.
So we haven't really
tried that yet here.
But I think we're going
to explore that option
a little bit more and see how
it affects the communication.
If it doesn't have
that much of an impact,
then we would use it.
PROFESSOR 3: Any final
questions or anything like that?
AUDIENCE: One quick thing
is you may [INAUDIBLE]
think about the shape,
the engineering of it.
There's some principles to
apply to kind of engineer
a shape that is most
effective for sound filtering
or sound blocking.
That kind of thing.
OK, Thank you.
Hi, so we're Team Jeffery.
JODIE CHEN: I'm Jodie.
DAVID KE: I'm David.
JODIE CHEN: And our
client is Jeffrey.
Here's a picture of
him, and he's blind.
So first, we're going to
talk about contextual inquiry
and how we worked
with the HAAT model.
So we came up with
a few questions
that we planned on
asking him to kind of get
an idea of what
activities he enjoys doing
and which activities
we can help streamline
or make more efficient and allow
him to, I guess, enjoy it more.
So we kind of
asked him questions
like, what activities
do you want
to be able to do independently?
And we asked him to
show as an activity
that he enjoyed in his
free time and also like
how he uses computers,
because it turns out
that he uses computers a lot.
So I think one
thing that we found
about Jeffrey is that he's
actually extremely independent,
even though he's blind.
He told us that like
75% of blind people
are like unemployed,
but he's been employed
in multiple places before,
and he also continues
to do a lot of financial work.
So we have a video to
kind of show, I guess,
how he's l challenged
our misconceptions.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, so I'm David, and
I'm part of Team Jeffrey
with Jodie Chen and Yi Tong.
And the client that we're
working with for PPAT, his name
is Jeffrey, and he's blind.
I guess initially going
into this project,
I didn't really know what I was
expecting in terms of working
with a person with blindness.
I guess, part of it's
like I didn't expect them
to be super self-sufficient.
And I thought they
would have to be
relying on a lot of technologies
to go through their day.
[? And so I was like ?] struggle
with like a decent portion
of the daily activities.
-I guess something that really
surprised me about Jeffrey
was how autonomous he is in
like his travel and other stuff.
So what you might not
know about Jeffrey
is that during our Monday and
Wednesday classes sessions as
well as class labs,
he actually comes over
and he listens and he also
participates in our team
discussions, gives all
of like helpful advice
as to like how do we
really work on the project
and how to build it.
-So I have plan
A, plan B, plan C,
and plan D. That's how you
have to live OK, so here we're
on my email.
-Jeffrey is-- you can
barely tell Jeffrey's blind
when he's at his
place because he knows
exactly where everything is.
He's really passionate
about technology.
-He is really passionate.
He told me that he as
the coolest gadgets.
-[INAUDIBLE]?
-What toys?
-You looked at this other wall
while you were sitting there.
I said, Jeff, what is it?
-I don't know.
-Remember, I said
when I got here
and he had this-- it's
a talking thermometer.
-Oh, it's a talking thermometer,
indoor/outdoor temperature.
Neil plays with it more than
I do because, frankly, I
don't give a damn.
It's too much information.
-The indoor temperature is
68.3 degrees Fahrenheit.
-I don't even know
how accurate it is.
It's a toy.
-And then he [? bought ?]
this when he started cooking.
It's a talking kitchen
thermometer-- a kitchen scale.
-Oh, yeah, I tell you, he
knows more the toys-- I forgot.
-Because I found them.
-(SINGING) Ah--
-Ah.
[END PLAYBACK]
JODIE CHEN: So here's some
information about Jeffrey.
So Jeffrey, he's
visually impaired,
and he has been kind
of for his whole life.
He used to be able to
see like different things
if you blew them up really
large on like a projector.
But now, all he can see is like
just like light and darkness.
So he's used computers
for practically his whole,
so he's actually very, very
good at using his JAWS screen
reading software.
And he actually
teaches people how
to use it in the Carroll
Center for the Blind.
And he also knows
braille, and he told us
that actually a
lot of blind people
don't know how to read
braille, so he's actually
one of the few
people that actually
does know how to read braille.
And he also does a lot
of financial paperwork
for his homeowner's
association for his condo,
and he does a lot of
taxes for his friends.
So he's constantly
on his computer,
checking his email, using
Excel to work on that.
So we kind of wanted to
narrow down like an activity
that Jeffrey has to do that he
wants, I guess, like more help
in.
So he's a pretty
opinionated person,
so he already had an idea
of what problems he exactly
wanted us to solve
and also solutions
as to how to solve them.
So on the activities that
he kind of narrowed down
for us is finding a way to
sign a paper with a wet ink
signature.
So he gets a lot of financial
sheets and documents from banks
and stuff that need him
to sign the document
and not have a
digital signature.
So in order to
sign a document, he
has to have his visual
aide Neil come over
and like help him find the
exact line where he has to sign.
And if he doesn't
have a visual aide,
then there's no way for
him to get that done.
And she also uses
Excel a lot, and he
doesn't like the
new format of Excel,
so he wants us to
kind of like change
it to be more compatible
with like the versions
that he's used to.
So we narrowed it down
to being able to help
him sign a document when he's
like independent and alone,
without a visual
aide to help him.
So to kind of get a better idea
of what we have to work with,
we kind of asked him like,
what assistive technologies
that he currently
use so to find out
which assistive technologies
that he was comfortable with.
So he told us that he's
really comfortable with JAWS,
and that like when he
does OCR on a document,
he can determine where a
signature line is because JAWS
will just say like, underscore,
underscore, underscore.
So all we had to do
is kind of find a way
to guide like his
mouse pointer to like
the position of the
underline and then
to find a way to convert
that into like something
that could be translated
onto a piece of paper.
So for our success
metrics we kind of wanted
to be able to evaluate
like how well he
can sign a document by seeing if
he can actually find the place
where to sign
independently on his own,
which he isn't able
to do right now.
And we also wanted to measure
like how long it takes
for him to measure a document.
And I guess that's
pretty easy to improve on
because currently it takes
infinite time for him to sign
a document.
And we also wanted
to measure kind
of how accurate he is
with finding the position
and also signing
because we don't
want him to sign
somewhere that's
really far away from the line.
So that's kind of
like the scope.
YI TONG: So I'm
just going to talk
about the project organization,
the progress so far.
So the first is the ideation.
So we're very lucky, so
Jeffrey's always in the lab,
as you all can see.
So he's been meeting
with us every lab
and also contributes
a lot of good ideas.
So we go to the lab with
ideas and then consult Jeffrey
and ask him for the feedback.
And then we narrow
down the solutions
after every discussion.
And then finally, we decided
on the mechi and software
combined solution.
So for the software
part, so we all
know that JAWS can
detect a signature line
and read out underscore
and also like signatures
and different kinds of words.
So we just need to find a way to
get coordinates from the mouse
location, and then take in the
mouse location two inches so
that that can be the
input for the mechi part.
So for mechanical
part, we need a frame
the holds standard sized
paper so it won't slide away.
And then we need sliding
braille rulers, or rails,
to move horizontally and
vertically so that Jeffrey can
adjust to the exacty x-,
y-coordinates by sliding
the two rails.
So here's the early sketches
and also the prototype
that we have.
So on the right is just
some white board drawings
about different ideas
that we had before.
So the first one you can say
something more or less like
the magnifier that we see
on [? Ability ?] [? Expo ?].
So basically the
advantage of that is he
doesn't have any restriction
while he's signing things.
But that is really hard to
implement because the camera's
on top of the paper.
And also we also get inspired
by the idea of a project built
by an MIT Media Lab.
So it's a finger reader, so
like whenever he scans a line,
he hears "signature."
Then he will start signing.
But then that would
require Jeffrey
to scan through the whole page.
And then so we finalized
on this sketch.
So there are two siting rulers.
Ideally, each ruler will
have like brailles on it
so that he can know how
far he's gone on the page.
So both rulers kind of slide
left and right and also
the other's up and down.
Yeah and then just the
idea-- you don't you read it.
But it's just how much
Jeffrey's input is given to us,
and also he's really
passionate about this project.
DAVID KE: So this is the general
timeline for what we're doing.
So in the next few
weeks, it's going
to be focused on mostly
making more prototypes
for these projects,
and we're really
ramping up our
interactions with Jeffrey
to get feedback and
iterate on our designs.
So like as you've seen
in the previous slides,
we already have a
really lo-fi prototype.
So what we're going to
do in the next two weeks
is prepare multiple versions
with minor detail differences
to Jeffrey to see
which ones he likes.
Because a lot of it, the
general idea is pretty solid,
but a lot of it's
like in the details
of how unexpected
things might come up
as he uses it day to day.
And in a few weeks, once we
kind of have that hammered out,
we'll try to work on
like a more high fidelity
prototype that this
more closer to what
we'll be presenting at the end
in the beginning of November.
And on the software side,
this is more like on our side
because we need to
kind of get familiar
with hows JAWS is working,
as well as like what kind
of inputs to outputs we can give
to JAWS as well as from JAWS.
And then we're aiming to sort
of complete that little bit
after hardware,
so we can kind of
combine it together and have a
few weeks to see how that would
work as a complete package.
And this is just what we've
done so far-- yay, teamwork.
OK, and that's the last slide.
YI TONG: Well, he obviously
had a lot of ideas,
and I'm wondering how
you chose, or what
process you used to choose
this signature project?
Was it sort of an embodiment
of your skills and interests,
or was it like clear
front runner for him?
DAVID KE: So I think
two main categories
we were considering
in that was, one,
is it something that
aligned with our skills,
because we're all
studying computer science.
He also had a bunch
of projects that
were pretty cool that
wasn't that involved,
like mostly mechanical
engineering.
So that was like a little out
of the reach of our abilities.
At the same time, something
else we have to consider
was we needed a project that was
the right scope for the class.
So like, for example, the
Excel thing he mentioned,
it's mostly computers,
but it was very simple.
So we wanted something that
had more substance to it that
could be applied to
more people afterwards.
PROFESSOR 1: I have a question
about your baseline success
metrics because you did say that
signing documents is something
does do with Neil's help.
Have you watched him to
do that with Niel's help?
Have you sort of collected
examples of his signature
that he's done with Neils help?
Seems like that you're not
just operating with something
that he's completely
unable to do,
but something he just
can't do independently yet.
JODIE CHEN: Well, he wants to
be able to do it independently
because Neil isn't always there.
And we haven't really had a
chance to watch Neil show him
where the signature line is and
how to sign it because, so far,
we've only gone to his
house once because he comes
to Monday, Wednesday
class sections,
but also lab sections,
so we've been
meeting with him for
around four hours
every week during class time.
DAVID KE: Yeah, but I
think that's a good idea,
and it's something we
should definitely do
the next time we meet with him.
I suspect we'll have
to consider that
as like two different
categories of like metrics,
but it's something
that should be included
PROFESSOR 2: So I'm curious
more about the mechanical aspect
then.
So you guys are really
comfortable with the software
side, and you presented
the first prototype
of the mechanical
side, and you've
showed kind of your sketch of
how the camera might be there
and where the rulers might be.
But you talked about
some of the limitations
potentially for just
being able to kind of look
at where you put your head,
where you put your hand.
I want you to talk
a little bit more
about some of those
limitations and things
you're thinking about
from the mechanical side,
and what you think you
might do to balance that.
YI TONG: I think I might have
misrepresented because I feel
like the camera thing is just
like the earlier prototypes
that we explored, but we're not
going to do the camera side.
We're just going to
keep the software part,
the mechi part separate.
So the mechi part
is independent.
It only takes in
the coordinates.
And then Jeffrey
will get feedback
when he's sliding the rulers,
so he knows how far he's gone,
but he doesn't have to
have a camera take down
where his hand is currently on.
DAVID KE: Yeah, and one
good thing about this
is I think Jeffrey
and us are pretty
aligned in that we
want to keep the amount
of complicated components in
the final project like minimized
to reduce possibility
of failure.
So a lot of the
things we've actually
talked about in
the past few weeks
are ways to simplify the
parts so that it still
has the relevant information,
but it's like as simple
as possible.
PROFESSOR 4: Any
questions or comments?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
using a mouse [INAUDIBLE].
But wouldn't that require him
to click all over the screen
to find out where the
signature line is, or are you
just going to have he
reads through it with JAWS
and then stops when
he finds lines.
JODIE CHEN: So it's more
likely to be like the latter
because he's done that.
For JAWS, when JAWS is reading
something on the screen,
it has a [INAUDIBLE] somewhat
similar [? to mouse clicks, ?]
but they're not actually
mouse [INAUDIBLE].
And then there's like
a function in JAWS
where it moves the mouse
pointer to the location of where
it's currently reading.
So that's how we're
planning on doing it.
PROFESSOR 4: Any
questions, comments?
So quick clarification, so
is there like a scanning--
maybe I missed it.
Is there some scanning
of the document first?
Are you buying a scanner?
JODIE CHEN: Oh, he always
scans in his documents.
AUDIENCE: I was hoping to
[INAUDIBLE] Jeffrey briefly.
Is it going to be an issue when
the line is like a drawn line,
as opposed to [INAUDIBLE] line?
Or will that resolve
with the scanner?
DAVID KE: That just depends on
like the of quality of the line
as well as like the character
recognition software.
So we'll probably
do tests with that
to see like how much
tolerance the software has.
PROFESSOR 4: Michelle,
last question.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a general location
where you know the
lines are going to be.
Just out of curiosity,
like if I sign a paper,
it's usually at the
bottom right-hand corner.
Do you guys have
an understanding
of what kind of documents
he's currently signing,
like what they look like?
YI TONG: According to Jeffrey,
I think it varies a lot.
And also sometimes like
there's a huge line,
but then the signature
word is under the line,
but sometimes it's
just next to it.
And then sometimes,
the signature's
right here on the left
of page, but then you
have to sign it to
the right of the page.
So it really depends on
different kinds of paperwork.
So we tried to collect all
different kinds of paperwork
that he normally
gets, and then we
tried to characterize like what
different kinds of signature
box that he normally gets
and then work on that.
JODIE CHEN: And also
what Jeffrey does
is he scans a document,
and then he runs OCR on it,
and then he translates
it into a Word document,
and then he prints out
the Word document to sign.
So what's going to happen is
that he alters the document
that he gets in mail
pretty significantly when
he runs OCR and changes
it to a Word document.
DAVID KE: But overall he gets
a lot of different signatures
on that.
PROFESSOR 2: It would be really
interesting to actually try out
that and get those documents for
all these different signature
lines.
And I think that's
a really good point
about whether it's an
underscore line or a drawn line,
and some signatures are actually
boxes as opposed to lines
and how that might affect it.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, thank you.
VYNNIE KONG: Everyone,
we are Team Beverly Ann.
This is our mid-semester review.
My name's Vynnie.
SHRUTHI NARAYANAN: I'm Shruthi.
ROBERT LUO : I'm Robert.
VYNNIE KONG: And
we're just going
to provide you a brief
introduction to our client.
So some of the non technical
things-- Beverly-Ann
is a social worker
for DCF, so that's
the Division of
Children with Families,
so she basically works
at a sort of law firm.
And she's actually
learning how to code using
and Scratch Arduino, which
we thought were pretty cool.
She loves playing Wi tennis.
She has a backyard
garden, so she
grows tomatoes and marigolds.
And most importantly, she wants
to maintain an active mind
in order to keep
busy and kind of like
find something useful
for the rest of her life.
And before we explain
more about stuff
related to the HAAT
model, we think
the video would be a
very good descriptor
of a lot of these things.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hello, my name is
Beverly Ann Rock,
and I have been
diagnosed with CMT, which
stands for Charcot-Marie-Tooth.
I was diagnosed
about 11 years ago.
If there's any blessings
to this disease
or anything good
about this disease, is
it only affects the
hands and the legs,
which means I'll always
have my ability to talk.
Three of my 10 fingers have
taken on the deformity, which
means they're kind of locked.
And eventually, they will
end up in gnarled positions.
But fortunately, 7
is better than none.
So I use my seven
fingers very effectively.
My right hand, it has
become numb in many places.
Thus it doesn't give
me the opportunity
to use very simple devices.
So if I were to be trying
to drink something hot,
I would make sure to try
to grip it as best I can
and support it.
But over time, it's
not going to hold.
It's going to slip, I'm
going to lose the grip.
That's one of my concerns
is dropping stuff
and why I'm so
guarded about dropping
is if you drop a glass, a
shard, I had a couple times,
a little thing has just
stuck into my foot,
and I didn't realize it
till I looked down and said,
why am I bleeding?
I Constantly fall, and I
always have devices or walkers
or scooters or things
that will enable
me to maintain balance
and continue to be mobile.
I choose, at this point
in my life, to work,
even though I'm
at retirement age,
and that's because it
keeps my mind busy.
And hopefully every day
they're working on a cure,
or I stumble on a
program like you
that is going to assist me to
make things a little easier.
So if I had a device
that was telling me,
if I got too into
the conversation,
that it's loosening, then I
when know to go back and not
use the assistance to go back
and try to tighten the grip.
-We have to distract
you some how.
-You are distracting me
because why you're talking,
I'm saying, OK, hold on.
[END PLAYBACK]
SHRUTHI NARAYANAN: So, as she
said in the video, she has CMT.
It's a neurodegenerative
disease that
affects the extremities,
so the hands and the feet.
It results in a loss of touch
sensation and muscle control.
So she has involuntary
muscle spasms.
For her, in particular, we're
interested in her hands.
So it means that she has sensory
failures in part of your hands
and muscle failure in others.
And this is like
a general diagram
of her left and right hand.
On her left hand, you can see
the green fingers are curled in
like this.
And that's because that's
their natural position.
So when she tries to open
them, they automatically
curl back in.
So this is like the
involuntary muscle movement.
But her other two
fingers are very mobile.
So even though she
can't grip anything just
with the left hand,
she uses her left hand
to support what
she's gripping a lot.
On her right hand,
the red regions,
which are most of
her fingers, are
the places where
her hands are numb,
so she can't feel anything.
And so she has a
hard time gripping
with those parts of her fingers.
But the tips of her fingertips,
which are marked in blue,
are actually fully sensitive.
So she tends to claw whenever
she's picking things up.
But over time, she still loses
grip with her right hand.
VYNNIE KONG: Because
of the combination
of loss of pressure and also
involuntary muscle movements,
there are certain activities
that Beverly Ann has trouble
with on a day-to-day basis.
And then I made a table
with modifications
that she's learned
to do to adapt.
So a lot of the things
she has trouble with
is having to consciously
think about doing
everything she does.
So any time she has to pick up
something to drink of water,
any time she has
to type something,
she needs to think about
every single letter she types,
rather than just typing
out of muscle memory.
And that's difficult,
especially when
you're holding a
conversation with someone
or if you're just thinking
about something else.
You can't always think about
what you're doing all the time.
This also helps with
walking down stairwells,
because she has to
grip onto the stairwell
and make sure she squeezes
every couple of seconds,
so if she's managed to stumble,
she'll still have the grip
and be able to
stabilize herself.
And the last thing is actually
cooking, which he brought up
in a meeting, where she realized
when she was cooking potatoes
and she was picking up
potatoes to put them in the pot
that she wasn't actually
grabbing on to them.
So she had to use this
sort of like clawing motion
to get them from the
cutting board into the pot.
ROBERT LUO : So the basic
problem we're dealing with here
is that she has to constantly
think about the things
she's grabbing whenever she's
grabbing some kind of object.
And also, she is not
really confident in using
just her right hand
for grabbing objects.
Instead she normally uses her
left hand to do the support.
And we want to come up with
the device which would help her
by notifying her when she
first-- helping her to have
the confidence to grab objects
with just her right hand,
and then notifying her whenever
her gripping starts to become
loose.
So then we came up with
the success metrics
for our project.
There are few things
we can think about.
So the first thing is we want
to see how much of a percentage
our device could
give her the warning.
So right now, of
course, it's zero.
But we think a
reasonable goal will 50%.
Meaning that our device
will be able to alert
her 50% of the time whenever
her grip starts to become loose,
and then with an
ambitious goal of 90%.
And then the second
success metric
is the dropping rate
with just her right hand.
And so this part we still need
to measure how many times,
how many things she drops
on average in a day,
and then we want
to decrease that
by 50% as our reasonable
goal, and 20% off the original
as our ambitious goal.
And then we want to boost her
confidence in gripping objects
with just her right hand.
And we can measure
how many times
she grabs things in a weekly
basis or a daily basis.
And then we want to increase
the percentage of her just
using her the right hand to grab
to 60%, then eventually 90%.
And so this is our design
process for this device.
So first, we define the goals.
So we noticed that she
has two different problems
for her left hand
and her right hand.
And after talking
with our mentor Jeff,
we decided to focus
on solving her problem
with the right hand, so
meaning the gripping part.
Then we brainstormed
of different ideas.
We mainly focused on whether
we should use a sensor,
and if yes, where
should we put the sensor
as well as how we can attach
the sensor to her hand?
Then we come with various
types of prototypes,
many based on the
location of the sensor
as well as the style of
attachment of the sensor.
So the fundamental
idea of our design
is to have a way to quantify
the pressures she exercises when
she grabs things
as well as trying
to have a way to notify her
when her grip becomes loose.
SHRUTHI NARAYANAN: So
the first concept we had
was to place the sensors near
the palm of her right hand,
so that would be in this area.
We figured that we
wanted as little material
on her hand as possible, so it
wouldn't weigh her down and so
that it wouldn't look like
a very obvious device.
And then on the
back of the hand,
you can see there's a square.
That would be where the
sensors read out to.
There would be
some sort of output
there that she could look
or that would notify her
when her grip is slipping.
So this was good because it
was very small and condensed,
and she'd still have
use of her fingers.
But it was bad because she tends
to grip with her fingertips.
So we wouldn't actually be
able to sense a lot of the grip
that she was using.
And so we would basically get
no reading most of the time
So then we came up with
an exciting concept,
which was to place the sensors
on the tips of the fingers.
If you can see, everything
except for the index finger
has a sensor.
That's because she actually
doesn't use your index finger
very much when gripping.
So the other four
fingers have sensors.
They wrap around
the back of the hand
to go to the same output box.
This is much better because she
grips with their fingertips,
so we can actually sense
what's she's gripping.
But it does take up
more of her hand.
In the end, we went
with a second concept,
and this is because we asked her
about how she felt about having
a device on her hand.
And she was like, I don't
care what it looks like.
It could be pretty big, and I
would be OK with that as long
as it helps me to grip.
So we made some very basic
prototypes of just the shape
of what they would look like.
So the sensors are the
sort of strips of paper,
and we just wanted
to see how they
would look so that we can
sort of experiment with how
they fit on her hand.
So if you want to--
VYNNIE KONG: So a bit
of a future timeline,
we are planning by next week,
so October 29th, to start
and basically
finished figuring out
the circuitry for connecting
these sensors to some sort
of output voltage, and we
want to tune the circuit so
that whatever output
voltage the sensors produce
will be in a format that's
interpretable to our needs.
SHRUTHI NARAYANAN: Then
we want to write code
to respond to the
sensor so that we
can give her a sort of output
on when she's losing grip.
So we want to study what
the sensor voltage looks
like as her grip loosens
and try to figure out
where we can start
notifying her,
when like this certain thing
happens that, oh, your grip is
loosening.
So we plan to try multiple
different algorithms for this,
and this will hopefully
be our second prototype,
and we'll have it done by
the first week of November.
ROBERT LUO : And then the third
step is the actual glove we
will use to attach
the sensor with.
So some things we want to
think about in this stage
is how we want to keep
the sensors safe, which
means we don't want
the sensors to be
exposed to the outside
environment as well
as her hand.
So maybe something
we're thinking about
is knitting two
layers of the gloves
together and having the
sensors to be in the middle.
So that could protect the sensor
from the outside environment
as well as her hand.
And then we also want to
think about questions like,
what happens to the sensors
when she curls her hand?
So the way we think
about it is that as long
as we put the sensor
on the back of her hand
or on the wristband,
it depends on which one
we choose eventually.
Both designs would able
to help stable, even
when she curls her hand.
And, of course, after we're
having the prototypes,
we want to keep improving on
the device based on our test
results with Beverly Ann.
VYNNIE KONG: A little bit
about our division of work--
so during our client
meetings, Shruthi
he has been primarily
doing the video.
I've been primarily doing
the interviews, and then
Robert, the notes.
And looking onwards,
Shruthi and I
will be planning
on working mostly
on the circuits, and then
Robert on most of the gloves
and figuring out what
materials to use.
And thank you,
guys, for listening.
If you have any
questions, let us know.
PROFESSOR 4: Questions
comments from [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 1: I'm
wondering if you thought
about what you
might do passively
with the material of
the glove to make it
less likely that it would slip?
You know what I mean?
You have a very active
solution right now
that depends on sensors and
electronics and batteries.
Are there anymore
passive things that you
might do, either with
material or with the design
of the glove, or
have you thought
about that part of the space?
SHRUTHI NARAYANAN: So
one of the big things
we thought about was when we
get the material for designing
the glove, to have
like sort of grip.
So certain gloves do
come with like rubber
on the outside of them
to have more grip,
and we thought that
something like this
would also be able
to help her generally
keep her grip on
slippery objects,
especially with the glove on.
So that's one example
of a passive solution.
We did think of entirely passive
solutions at the beginning,
like having some sort
of exoskeleton that
would like hold her group
in place that she could
lock into place or something.
But we figured that then
she'd be having to manipulate
the device too much herself.
And so we went with the more
active solution in general.
But yes, smaller passive
things, like the rubber grips
and having some fingers open
so that she has better grip,
will hopefully help her
with her grip anyways.
VYNNIE KONG: And we
actually found out
that a lot of her problems don't
come from muscular strength.
So it's not that she can't
physically lift the plate.
It's just that she can't feel
how hard she's gripping it.
So balancing it becomes a
bit of an issue, for example.
PROFESSOR 5: Well, following
on what you just said,
did you think of any
sort of way of giving
maybe auditory
feedback or some way
to in terms of the gripping,
like is there a user interface
aspect to this?
ROBERT LUO : Right, so some
things we think about is
so after having a sensors, we
want to be able to quantify her
grip.
And so some things
we are thinking about
is we can test how much of a
grip she exercises on an object
initially, and then set
that as a threshold.
And whenever the grip comes down
to 50% of the original grip,
then that's the threshold
we think of warning her.
And then and then the
ways of warning her
include having a beeping
sound, or it vibrates
so she will be notified.
PROFESSOR 5: Did you
think about cost?
Did you say cost,
like what it would
cost to make one of these
in quantity or something?
ROBERT LUO : Oh, right, so we
already have the sensors ready.
So we already got the sensors,
so they were not too expensive.
They were $60, $70.
And then we know are on
the stage of figuring out
how the circuits would work,
and we would approach it
by making it on a
breadboard first,
then thinking of whether
it's possible to make
this circuits into a
smaller circuit board
and attaching it to the glove.
And then the glove
itself shouldn't really
be that expensive.
PROFESSOR 5: Any quick
questions from the audience?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
VYNNIE KONG: We have not.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's like
thread that's in buckets,
so it's like a wire,
but it's thread.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SHRUTHI NARAYANAN: Yeah,
I guess like once we
have the sensors
attached inside the glove
to get it to the output,
we could use that.
Thank you for the idea.
STUDENT 1: Hi,
we're team Barbara.
So this is Barbara.
She has been a
teacher for 29 years,
but she had to retire
early because she has PLS.
So PLS is kind of like ALS.
It's a disease where
your muscles get weaker.
And right now she is living in
the Leonard Florence Center,
and she really
values independence.
And as of right now, she has
fine motor skills in her hands,
but is slowly losing
her strength, especially
in her left hand
because she does
a lot of crocheting during
her free time, which keeps
her right hand more flexible.
And she's also constrained
to a wheelchair,
and her speech is
sometimes unclear
because the muscles in her
face are also weakening.
So some of the activities
that she has trouble with
is opening and closing
the door in her room.
This is her door.
And it's difficult for because
the door is very heavy,
and also it does not swing open.
When she's trying to open
it, it stays where you
leave it and locks in place.
Also, because her
wheelchair gets in the way
because the door
opens towards her,
so she has to open
it a little bit.
scoot her chair back,
and then open it some
more, which makes
it very difficult.
Another problem that
she has is turning off
the lights before she goes
to sleep because once she's
in bed, it's very
difficult for her to get up
and turn off the lights.
Currently, she has an
iPhone, and on her iPhone,
these are some of
the apps that she
uses for assistive technology.
The ones on the
bottom here, some
are for speaking because
her speech is unclear.
So, for example, there's one
for her to say yes or no,
and some of them where
she can type in phrases,
and it'll speak it for her.
Or there's also apps for her
to indicate the amount of pain
she has right now.
She also recently
got an iPad, but she
hasn't been using it that
much because it's heavy.
But she has no
assistive technology
that she uses currently
for opening the door
or turning out the lights.
So some of the context is
that her room is right next
to the dining area,
so sometimes there's
a lot of noise that bothers her.
Also, she has
concern for privacy
because since the door
is so hard to open,
she leaves it open
most of the time.
And right now, the staff at
the Leonard Florence Center
has to open and close
the door for every day
and turn on and off the lights.
And although she didn't ask
for a solution for her voice
problem, she did
tell us that this
is a major concern for her.
So based on my
contextual inquiry,
we decided on our
project, which is
to automate the door
because she really
wants to have the independence
to be able to open and close
the door by herself, and also
have privacy in her room,
and she doesn't currently
have any assistive technology
for that.
And that is like the most
difficult problem for her right
now.
So for success metrics we think
the best possible solution
would be for her to
have an app on her phone
that she would just be able
to click or some sensors,
so she doesn't have to
actually opened the door.
And a less successful
solution would be for her
to press a button and
something that would just
be able to reduce the
amount of effort she needs
is to have her pull something
that would then open the door,
instead of actually
opening the door itself.
STUDENT 2: So next
we're going to explain
a little bit about our
ideation process for this door.
So we're going to
start by showing you
a video of our design process
and to give you a bit of sense.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This place, the Leonard
Florence Center, is wonderful.
They encourage you to be
independent the best you can.
I like the attitude.
Hello, my name is
Barbara [INAUDIBLE].
I was a teacher for 29
years before I got sick.
I had to retire early.
I miss the kids.
I miss the nonsense.
-What are your typical
daily activities?
-Some days Bingo.
I never played Bingo
before I came here.
It's to socialize more.
I struggle with the door
since my room is so small.
I'm in my own way
with the chair,
so to make it so it's easier
without crashing into the door.
The doors are very
heavy for my left arm.
Automatic doors in the
room, would be very helpful.
-What would be your
perfect world interaction
with the door?
-I can open and close
it without touching it.
Some of the rooms already
have the technology.
Mine doesn't.
-So it's easy to open it.
But then once it's not moving,
it's hard to do either.
Also, like the door
will not swing open,
so you can't just
push it because it
doesn't let it happen.
It locks itself.
-Then we began our
design process,
which consisted of
numerous measurements
on everything related
to Barbara's door.
We then considered whether
we wanted an app, button,
or mechanical solution and
started our ideation process.
These ranged from an
automatic collapsible door
that opens with a pulley,
to a mechanical lever
that closes the door
when you push on it,
as well as a pulley system that
opens and closes the door when
you pull on the string.
And lastly, we considered an
automatic soundproof curtain
system which would open with a
touch of a button from pulleys.
We decided to pursue
the curtain idea,
and are now beginning to
prototype over and over
and over again until we create
the perfect automatic door.
STUDENT 2: So that's just an
overview of our design process.
So I'm going to take you
through the specifics of it now.
So these are the three idea that
we were pursuing for the door.
And the first thing
that we did was
weigh the pros and cons
of each possibility.
So with the automatic
collapsible door,
we thought that this would
serve as a good alternative
because it's rigid,
so it does still
have the appearance of a door.
But some issues we
had with is that it
was hard to find the parts
to create a rigid collapsible
door that was cheap and
easy to put together.
Next, we considered automatic
curtains, which we thought
would be very easy to
implement and test,
and we get soundproof
curtains that could
implement that part of it.
But one issue is that it
might not be door-like enough
and fit in with like the norms
of what doors simply look like,
and the pulley system
could get stuck as well.
Lastly, we considered a
mechanical lever and pulley
system, so this would
alter the door itself,
so we wouldn't have
any extra parts,
and it should make the whole
thing flow a little bit more
smoothly.
But it's kind of
hard to implement,
as we are not mechanical
engineering students.
So we decided to go with
the middle approach,
as it is very easy to
test and prototype.
But when we went to the
Leonard Florence Center
with our idea to see if
there were any issues,
we found that there were a lot.
One of the first ones is
that they consider curtains
a major fire hazard because
she could get stuck,
or the curtains could get in the
way of her leaving or entering
her room.
They also told is that this
idea must be fail proof.
So if there were a fire, the
door must be able to close,
and nothing should
inhibit its way.
So we tried to brainstorm
another solution,
and decided to go with
our mechanical approach.
But there we found
that if we connected it
with the fire alarm system,
we could get our pulley
to dislodge from the door if
the fire alarm system goes off.
And then this
would hopefully not
in impede with the
door's mechanism
when there is a fire alarm.
But still they raised the
problems of a fire hazard, that
must be fail proof, and
they also did not really
understand how we would
connect our new door system
to the main system itself.
And if we were to go through the
peak system that is currently
at the Leonard Florence
Center, it's super expensive.
And so we found it this idea
is not very feasible for us.
So this led us to work into
her secondary problem, which
is light automation.
So the reason why this was her
secondary preferences it's she,
with third condition
of PLS, she actually
can't get up from her bed to
shut off the light before she
goes to bed.
So she has to call
a nurse to do so.
So this impedes on
her independence.
This happens every day.
So this would be a problem
that if we could solve,
it would help
frequently, so she'd
be able to have
very good use of it.
It's not like a
one-case scenario.
And this will also help her
because in the future, when
she is in a
wheelchair, she may not
be able to have the
strength to reach up
to the light to switch.
Whereas with an application,
she could, since PLS
is progressive.
So as a condition worsens
this would be one of the this
will be a possible solution
that can like at least
allow her to shut off the
light when she wants to,
and she's not in her bed
for a longer period of time.
So different processes
we thought of doing this,
we thought of using X10.
So while we were
searching, we found X10,
so it's possible through Wi-Fi
to send a signal to the X10
transceiver.
That sends a message
to the outlet
through electricity, some
sort of like Morse code
for electricity kind of, to
give an idea of what it's doing.
And then that can be used
to turn on or off the light.
So the process would be a
little straight forward,
since the products
are available.
It would just be
us connecting them,
and then the actual
application already exists.
And the price tag
was about $100.
Another idea we thought
of was a more hands
on approach of getting in
Arduino to send a radio
frequency signal to the light.
We could buy the light that have
as a receiver for this radio
frequency signal.
So then we would basically
send a Bluetooth signal
from her phone to the
Arduino [? BLE ?] shield,
and then that would
send the signal
to the corresponding light.
So this was an option
that we could also
have that basically
we just have to have
multiple receivers, radio
frequency receivers that
are on the bottom
right hand corner.
So then she could
send different signals
from her phone to control each
and every light independently.
So it was an approach
we thought of.
The price tag on
it was about $70
because we would have to have
the [? BLE ?] shield as well
as the Arduino.
And then the outlet,
the receiver,
was also a little bit of cash.
So then after that
we like started
trying to come up with how
we were going to do this.
And our next idea was WeMo.
We saw this online.
Basically, they have
their own solution for it.
Basically, you can connect
to it through an application
that they already have provided.
The application is free, and
the product actually costs $41.
So we thought of having this
implemented in her system
and then possibly expanding
the SDK for the application
so that she could have
an easier time using it,
and then have it
basically tailored to her
so that she only had to
look at the application
and touch larger buttons
since the buttons are
a little smaller
than we would hope.
Possible next steps
is what I just
said, where we expand
an application based
off the SDK for WeMo and make
that app available for her.
Or if this ends up being a
solution right of the shell,
then we could possibly
taken an avenue where
after fixing this light
problem with WeMo,
go into the voice
applications so try and see
if we can tailor voice
application for her.
So our timeline is by
the end of October,
we hope to have WeMo installed.
The first half of
November we hope
to prototype the like UI
for either the voice app,
also, possibly, if
necessary, the light app.
Second half, we would like
to have this app done in iOS.
The reason for prototyping
[INAUDIBLE] it's faster,
and we can get a lot of
the UI feel really quickly.
And then after
that we would just
keep testing and iterating
until we have a product that
fits Barbara's needs.
Any questions?
PROFESSOR 1: Could you
say a bit about how
you're going to divide the
work among the three of you?
STUDENT 3: OK, so in terms
of the work for the door,
we've been all
going to the center
to speak with as many
people as possible.
So for the time
being, it's been a lot
of contextual inquiry and a lot
like designing all together.
But in terms of the next
steps for installing the WeMo,
we were going to go
to the center together
and while two of
the members were
going to be working on
installing this in the room,
we were also going to continue
to ask about the door,
we are pushing towards
like at least speaking
to a lot of members in
the center about the door,
since that is an issue
that we would hope
would be solved in the future.
After that is installed, the
dividing the actual application
process, so since we,
as a team, don't all
have like skills in
App Inventor and iOS,
we were going to divide
up so that we would end up
having some of the base
code that would definitely
be necessary for iOS built
right from the beginning
while the UI is being
prototyping in App Inventor.
So in terms of
like team specific,
it would be two members
working on the iOS application,
while one member just
continually prototypes
the ideas that the team comes
up with in App Inventory
to like give a feel for it.
We would always go as a team
to show this to Barbara.
And then once the App
Inventor UI decision is made,
we would all be
working on the iOS apps
since that's going to be
the majority of the part.
Any other questions?
PROFESSOR 5: So
basically, the door
is sort of too
hard is basically--
it's just not workable?
STUDENT 2: There a lot of
regulations with the door.
We'd have to get it
approved by the fire
department, the public health
department, and the people
at the center, a lot
of them don't even
know how it functions
and how it connects up
to like the central system
that closes all the doors when
a fire alarm goes off.
So it would require
a lot more research,
and we're not sure if
it's feasible to finish
this project in the next two
or three months that we have.
JESSICA HERRING:
So we are Team Art.
I'm Jessica.
RACHEL ELLISON: Rachel.
STEPHANIE CHEN : I'm Stephanie.
JESSICA HERRING: And what
we have decided to build
is a power lift.
So first, we're going
to introduce our client.
His name is Art.
He is an adaptive rock
climber, a hacker, a tinkerer.
He likes to build
stuff-- adapt stuff
to his specifications
and his desires,
and he's a very active
member of his community.
He has a girlfriend, and she
works in his hacker space
at the Artisans
Asylum in Somerville,
which is pretty much
a hacker space, where
people build stuff.
However, he has T5 Asia
B Paraplegia, which
is an incomplete paraplegic.
So he has some sensory
function below his waist,
but no motor function.
In addition to this, he has
a grade 2 shoulder separation
that is not quite bad
enough to need surgery,
but we do want to consider
this when making our design.
We don't want to make our
mechanisms too manual.
So Art wants to be able
to work on the floor.
He wants to be able to get under
some of his bigger projects,
like he'll lift up a wheelchair
on his lift that he's designed,
and he'll want to get under it.
But it's really
hard to do that when
you're getting out
of a wheelchair
and you can't move your legs.
So, in addition to that, if you
were to fall out of his chair,
he would like to be able to
use something to get back up
alone independently.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Well, I'm a [INAUDIBLE] minded
person, a lot of independence.
Before I got hurt
in March of 2010,
I was the person who took
care of all of our household
maintenance.
I did a lot of
motorcycle repair.
[INAUDIBLE]
Pretty much [INAUDIBLE],
I worked on it.
Now, I still try to do
as much of that as I can.
We're filming this at
Artisan's Asylum, which
is one of the world's
largest hacker spaces,
maker spaces and
collaborative workshops
that anyone [INAUDIBLE].
We have shops that cover an
incredibly wide range of skills
and technology.
What they call a T-5 Asia B,
which basically means that
from about here down I
have no motor function.
Because I can't get in and
out of my chair easily,
I'm more or less
limited to doing things
that I can sit in front of.
[END PLAYBACK]
JESSICA HERRING: He
is quite a character,
and he's very specific
about he wants.
But we figure that we can
help him out with that.
So our goal is to design
something that's portable,
something that's
lightweight, something
that is about the
height of his chair
that he can get in and out
of and get up and down with.
So the height of the
wheelchair seat-- Art cat
only move about three or four
inches vertically by himself.
And so we need our device
to be about the height
of his wheelchair seat,
which is 22 inches tall,
but we'd also like it to be used
anywhere he wants to use it.
So we originally wanted him to
be able to take it with him,
and that's still
one of our goals.
We also need it to
weigh under 20 pounds.
This is because he
wants his girlfriend
to be able to take it to him
if he falls out of his chair
and needs it or for
some other reason.
His girlfriend can
only lift 20 pounds
because she has a medical
condition that restricts that.
So our major success
metric is time.
A lot of these
design constraints
will make or break the project,
but the time is a variable.
So we would like it to be
approximately one minute.
Art wanted something a
little more like 30 seconds
to 45 seconds, but we think
a minute would also be OK.
STEPHANIE CHEN : So after
taking these design limitations
into account, we decided to
look into products that were
commercially available.
So at first, we began looking
into commercially available
medical technology.
For example, that up
there is something called
an [? elk ?] emergency lift.
It's probably the most
ideal out of these products
for our client because it
weighs approximately five pounds
and it can support 1,000 pounds.
The only problem with it is
that it costs $3,000 at least,
and there's no guaranteed
stability if he's actually
lifting in the chair.
There's nothing preventing
them from falling to the side.
And just for fun,
we decided to look
into other types
of lifting cushions
available in other industries.
We actually found something
called the Map Jack, which
is something similar.
It costs about $800, and it
can lift probably six tons--
fun fact.
We then decided to look into the
idea of a scissor lift, which
is a relatively prevalent
lifting mechanism.
You can find it in construction
sites and warehouses and so on.
The problem with that
idea is that there
is a lot of friction losses
associated with scissor lifts,
and considering the
fact that none of us
are mechanical
engineers, we decided
it would be best if we
started off with something
a little simpler.
And actually, if we consider
the weight of a scissor lift
into account, it would certainly
weigh more than 20 pounds.
We then decided to look into a
pool lift, which Art actually
owns.
The main issue with this idea
is that unfortunately it's
stationary, and we require a
very powerful linear actuator,
so we decided to
scrap those ideas.
One idea that we
actually came across
is something similar to
one of those stair lifts.
It's essentially a sliding lift.
It'll bring someone who's not
capable of going to upstairs
from the bottom to the
top of their staircase.
And Art was actually in
preference of this idea.
As you can see, based
on the lower sketch,
it appears to be
relatively light design.
And it's incredibly portable
because it essentially
looked like a tripod.
And unfortunately, the
major disadvantages of this
is we, again, have to deal
with a lot of friction losses,
and we also have
to include a bunch
of fail safes such
as hand brakes,
just to ensure that he doesn't
accidentally slide down when
he's near the top of the ramp.
And for this design
we actually need
a very specialized motor,
something that's low speed
and high in torque.
One idea that-- so
this is actually our
currently most worked done idea.
It's a screw lift essentially.
And that is a smaller
scale prototype.
Based on this drawing, you
can see that we essentially
take multiple 80-20
rods and arrange them
in that sort of fashion, so
you have one rod on this side
and one rod on the other, where
there's a seat in the middle.
And in between those two
rods, and what's holding up
the chair, is a threaded rod.
So essentially we'd
be using either
a drill motor or
any sort of motor
to twist that threaded
rod to lift or to cause
the chair to ascend or descend.
The major advantage
to this is it
can be designed to
be rather foldable,
and we don't have to
build in any fail safes
because we're dealing
with a threaded rod.
And actually, the motors
required for this design
are also relatively cheaper.
But the major
disadvantages to this idea,
in particular, is that we have
to work with multiple parts,
and this could be a
potentially heavy idea.
So here is actually a
video of the prototype.
RACHEL ELLISON: So this
showing it does move.
This me turning it by hand.
And so if you're turning
it at maybe 100, 150,
it would be moving a lot faster.
The [INAUDIBLE] we're looking
at are eight turns per inch.
So at 22 inches, we are
looking at about 200 turns.
So the next steps in
our process really
are to expand on these
two ideas and decide
which design to pursue.
Stephanie is handing
around now 80-20
rod, which is the basis
of our sliding mechanism.
And really what
we're trying to do
is understand what
parts we'll be
able to get within
our budget constraints
and which one will
provide a lighter weight
design that fits more of
our design specifications.
We'd like it to be full
scale, our next prototype,
and we're going to prioritize
durability and sturdiness.
After that, we'd like to make
a more polished prototype
of our final idea.
We'd like this one to fold
up to be transportable
and to be within our
weight specifications.
For our first
prototype, we're not
going to worry so
much about that.
We'd like to try to
optimize the lifting
time and the speed at
which the motor turns
to lift Art up and down.
And finally, we'd like to
think about the feasibility
of mass production
of this device
and what is going into it
and whether those things will
be available for other users.
And so our projected costs
with the slider design
which is a little bit
more expensive we're
going to need a linear bearing
to slide up and down the broad
with hand brake built
in so that it will be
stable at the top of the ramp.
And that's about $65.
For a high torque,
low speed motor,
those are pretty pricey
and come at $60 to $80 new.
We've been looking into
scavenging this part
to try to cut down costs.
We'll also need other parts,
such as hinges and legs,
so that'll fold up.
For the screw lift
design, we're looking
at using a threaded rod,
and this Acme thread design
is a special kind of threading
designed to bear weight
and not snag so that we can turn
it hopefully at higher speeds.
We'll also need a low
torque, higher speed motor.
Those will be
significantly cheaper,
and actually we have several
of those on hand right now.
And the rest of
the lift is going
to be aluminum or
wooden parts which can
come from the hardware store.
So with that, I'd like to
thank teammates Jessica, who's
been in charge of
videotaping our meetings
and edited both the lovely
videos you saw earlier,
Stephanie, who's been
heading up our prototyping
and is going to be
doing a lot of stuff
with building in
the next few weeks,
and then I'm not
going to thank myself,
but I've been doing a lot of
the interviewing and client
communication.
We'd also like to give a
special thanks to Don Fredette
at The Boston House,
who's provided us
with a lot of guidance,
parts, moral support, Joseph
Parse, in the Department
of Material Science
and Engineering, who helped
us figure out the screw lift
design and what parts
we'd need to make it work,
and finally our client
himself has helped us
a lot with the design
feasibility and sourcing parts,
and since he works
at this hacker space,
he's also volunteered to
help us put it together,
and, of course, the PPAT staff
makes this class possible.
Any questions?
PROFESSOR 4: We have about
three minutes for questions.
PROFESSOR 4: Have you looked
at Kiva Systems, a robot
for warehouse automation?
They were bought
for $600 million
by Amazon a couple years ago.
But they have a lift, a
clever lift mechanism.
Their founder talked to
[? Mickey ?] last week.
Maybe I can give you
a pointer or two.
They have a clever design.
Maybe it's the same.
But I do worry about the overall
electromechanical robustness.
Have you thought about
how the whole-- the power,
the connectors, the control
everything puts together?
RACHEL ELLISON: We should
have said something about this
during the presentation,
but Art has
hacked into 24 volt
battery system in his chair
and has an Anderson
volt connector that we
can use to power our devices.
PROFESSOR 4: So you'll connect
in to the wheelchair battery.
PROFESSOR 6: So that partly
answered one of my question.
I had two.
One, what equipment does Art
use at makers space, and two,
has he adapted or hacked
any of his existing?
So yes, he has hacked
his wheelchair.
JESSICA HERRING: He does that
quite frequently actually.
He replaces his joystick.
He [INAUDIBLE] adjust the
sensitivity for [INAUDIBLE].
RACHEL ELLISON: I think
he uses the [INAUDIBLE],
and he's built this foot peddle
to help him use variable speed
devices.
He can't use his feet.
I'm not sure
realistically how much
he's going to be able to help
us with putting it together.
But we thought it was
really kind that he offered,
and maybe there will be things
that he's able to assist with.
PROFESSOR 6:
[INAUDIBLE] it could
be interesting to think about
then going forward, even
beyond the class, how
do you design this
so that he can
continue tinkering
with it after the
semester is done,
if he's already in
a position and is
interested in doing that.
That's great.
PROFESSOR 1: So this is
interesting in the sense
that he's intentionally
on the ground, right?
You're not trying to
recover from fall,
which I think is where many
of the other assistive devices
are thinking about.
I want to actually probe
on this one minute time
because if he's intentionally
getting on the ground,
he's maybe planning
to get back up,
and he might do it, in fact,
frequently-- getting under,
getting back in the chair to
go somewhere else for a tool,
then going back and
getting under again.
Does the one minute that you're
talking about, is that just
measuring the time that
it takes like the motor
to propel him up to
wheelchair height,
or are we talking about the time
to set it all up, get on it,
as well as move up?
STEPHANIE CHEN : That's the
time he wants to spend actually
maneuvering himself on
the floor to his chair.
So we haven't actually taken
into consideration setup time,
though I guess that's
another thing we can add in.
But, again, that's going
to depend on the design
we choose, but some
may be, I guess,
modular in the sense that
it may take some [INAUDIBLE]
apart and actually have to
assemble the entire apparatus.
But for now, we're just
focusing on the time length
between him getting
from the floor
to the chair or vice versa.
RACHEL ELLISON: So
another reason to favor
this screw lift
over the slider lift
is that that's a lot more
flexibility in how fast
the thing goes up and down.
With a slider lift,
because so much torque
is required to just
move a pulley that way,
we'd be looking at-- we have a
minimum possible time of about
45 seconds.
Whereas with the screw
lift, pretty much the faster
you turn the motor, the
faster the thing moves.
And then the only
top consideration
really is how fast we
can move it safely.
We certainly don't
want to put him
in risk of being
propelled off the chair
or dumped onto the floor.
PROFESSOR 1: I'd
encourage you to include
setup time as one of
your metrics for at least
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 4: OK, any final
questions or comments?
All right, thank you, Team Art.
And we'll jump right in.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
We're team Chris.
So I'll introduce ourselves.
This is Arthie.
She's a senior, and
she is our point
of contact for the semester
with our client, who
we'll introduce later.
Next is Carolyn
right over there.
She is also a senior,
and she is the person
in charge of keeping us on
task during our meetings,
make sure focused, and make sure
that we're following our goals
and aiming for
goals every meeting.
PHOEBE: Next, we have
Dirk, who's a junior,
and he is our main
scribe for the semester.
And then there's me, Phoebe.
I'm the main photographer and
videographer for this semester.
And, of course, our most
important member of the team
is Chris.
He is a first year MBA
student at Boston College.
He loves to read, blog,
and he loves baseball.
So he has this rare
condition called
Miyoshi Myopathy, which is a
progressive muscular dystrophy
condition.
So he can only walk
short distances
and can only carry a
small load at a time.
STUDENT 4: The
activity that Chris
would like us to
help him with is just
as daily movements
throughout the world.
Since he uses forearm
crutches and a scooter,
he needs place that don't have
stairs and elevators to get
around.
Currently, when he
wants to go anywhere,
he has to research
that place online.
He uses Google Maps,
and he uses Yelp.
Yelp has a little
bit of information.
But really what he uses is the
Google Maps Street View feature
because he can actually
see where he can get up
onto a sidewalk
or the front door,
if there's stairs up to the
door and things like that.
If he can't get
enough information
from online resources,
sometimes he
can call the building,
the restaurant, whatever
he wants to do, and
they can give him
some more information that way.
On campus, he primarily uses
the disabilities office,
and oftentimes he
has to go in and talk
to them because there's
not very much information
on their website.
And can you go back?
One thing that's really hard
about some of these things,
except for the phone
call, of course,
is that he doesn't know what's
going on inside the building.
He can't see that on
a virtual application.
So we've decided he needs this
in everywhere that he goes,
but we've decided for
the scope of the class
to focus on his school
and Boston College.
Particularly, we're
starting with the building
that he uses every day,
which is Fulton Hall.
One thing about Boston College
is that it's very hilly.
So for Chris, that's really
difficult. Some of the paths
are sort of ramps up the
hills, but they're very steep,
which can be difficult for
his chair and also scary.
If he's going down, he
might not be able to stop.
And there's a lot of stairs
on some of these paths.
So actually he needs to go
through buildings sometimes
and use elevators
within the buildings
to get from a lower
level of campus
to a higher level or vice versa.
And then he's a
very busy students.
So if he needs a route
like that that's not easy
for him to see online,
he might take a long time
to get to his meetings
or his classes,
and that's a problem for him.
And the other thing is
students on campus don't really
know these routes, and
they're also very busy,
so it's hard for them to
help him out sometimes.
So our goal is to
take the things
that he uses right now-- Google,
Yelp, knowing about stairs,
and just going out
trial and error,
and finding these warnings
by himself-- we're
trying to take that uncertainty
and bring all of these elements
together into a
central application
that he can just go to
this one place, see a map,
and also go inside
buildings and find out
what things might be difficult.
If an elevator isn't working.
If an automatic
door isn't working,
if there happens to be something
in the middle of the hallway
that could be in his way, or
a classroom that has stairs up
to the seats, so he knows
about these things in advance
and doesn't have to deal
with that uncertainty
that he deals with every day.
DIRK: So Chris came
into this project having
a pretty good idea of what
he wanted us to create,
and that is an
application that presents
him all of this information
in an easily accessible form.
So our first goal was we needed
to narrow down the scope, which
we decided was Boston College.
And even more than
that, we decided
to look at three different
tiers of information.
So the first one being
at the building level.
So this would entail
essentially being
able to see the
entrances and exits that
are accessible to
buildings, being
able to see information that is
things like potholes or places
like hills that are hard to
access outside of the building.
The second tier is that
of the floor level,
actually being able to
look into the buildings
and seeing where the
locations of elevators
are, if there's
stairs to get places,
where the accessible
bathrooms are located.
And then the third tier is
that of rooms, in particular,
if there are difficult
doors to get in,
if it's like a lecture
hall where the accessible
seating is, which
entrances he can use,
and being able to present all
of that in a tiered format.
So for our goals, we
want to definitely
be able to do the first
and the second level.
We think those
are both feasible.
We're hoping to get to
the third tier as well.
Beyond that, there are
two different aspects
the application, that being
the front end and the back end.
The front end is the
visual display, what
Chris will actually be using.
And the back end is where
this data that is being
displayed actually comes from.
Now, the interesting
aspect of this project
is that because it
is navigation-based,
it's based on buildings and
wherever Chris wants to go,
ultimately his vision is to have
this available for everywhere
he wants to go.
Obviously, that's not all
feasible for the scope
of this project.
But we really want to have
some sort of method built
in that allows us to
expand to future locations
and be able to bring
in different locations
to this application.
So we want to, alongside
the front end on display,
have some sort of
method for bringing
in new places and new
data into the application.
As far as our actual
prototypes go,
we initially started by all
four of us creating drawings
explaining how sort of we
saw this application coming
together, and we presented
all of these to Chris
and discussed with him what
he liked about each of them,
and took the best
aspects of each,
and condensed them down into
a singular paper prototype.
So initially, he
liked the map view
that showed each
of the buildings
with alerts for where
the entrances are
and then being able
to have things pop up,
such as potholes,
things outside actually
getting to the building the
he might need to be aware of.
Then, when he actually
clicked on the building,
it would show up a
actual floor plan,
being able to look at different
floors within the building.
He liked the floor plan because
it was very easy to navigate.
And on top of that, having
different notifications,
different alerts,
potentially color-coded
that show different
pieces of information,
being where there are doors,
stairs, elevators, bathrooms,
all this information
that he wanted to be
able to see very easily marked.
One of the other big things
that he wanted to make sure of
is that we were presenting
just facts about the building.
He wants the information to be
presented in a fairly raw form
so he can then determine for
himself this is somewhere
I can go, or this is
somewhere I can't go.
As far as actually
creating this,
we decided on a web application
because it was easier for us,
as far as our skills
coming in, and it
was a lot more universal.
He can access it from his
phone, from this computer.
And then we want to use
JavaScript Node Express as far
as our languages to be
able to code that and Mongo
for our database structure.
The success metrics
that we want to use
to measure this apply
to the user experience
side of this project, to make
sure that Chris is getting
the most benefit out
of the application
that we're creating.
And so one of the
metrics that we are using
is the number of
clicks it's going
to take Chris to get a
specific item of information
that he needs.
So, for instance, starting
from the full campus map,
we want him to only have
to click three times
to get a specific floor
plan of a building
that he wants to
go into for class.
And upon that, click
only one more time
to look at a specific
room in that building
or the specific elevator
and to get the information
that you need to know for
that specific facility.
The second metric that
we are going to use
is how much time it takes for
him to gather this information.
So, as we mentioned
earlier, his current methods
are to call the
restaurant he's going to,
call the disabilities office,
look at their website,
and just look
through Google Maps.
And so we want to
be able to time
how long it takes him to
get to find information
about a specific classroom
through those ways,
and then make sure that
it's about 60% less
time for him to use our website
to get that same information.
The third metric we're using is
to allow for uncertainty-- not
allow for uncertainty, but to
reduce as much uncertainty as
possible.
And so that way
within our website,
he's not confused when
using it, and so we
want to count how
many questions he has,
and have a little help menu that
he can use to clarify things.
But also just to
reduce uncertainty
within all of his
travel procedures
and to allow him to answer
his questions before actually
going out.
Now for our future
plans of what we're
doing for the rest of the
semester, as Dirk mentioned,
we're going to split this into
the back end and the front end.
So Dirk and Caroline
are going to work on
in the data aggregation
and database set up,
so getting all the information
that we want to display
and then creating a database
structure that we can scope
later on to add more details--
different types of buildings,
different floors,
different facilities.
And Phoebe and I are going to
be working on the front end
to increase the user
usability of the whole design.
And since Chris
wants actual facts
that he can interpret
for himself,
we want to have a good
balance of images and text
and just make sure
that he's able to use
this in a clear way.
The timeline for this semester
is until the end of October,
we want to start
our coding process
and come up with a
software prototype,
and in the first
week of November,
work through our
software prototype,
and by the end of that, have
something to present to Chris
and have him actually
test it and use it
so that way we can
revise and reiterate
and keep going with it.
And by the end of
November, we want
to have our final version
that we can continue
to reiterate throughout.
And that's it.
Any questions?
PROFESSOR 5: All right, we have
four minutes for questions.
Have you tried to work
with Boston College
to get the actual floor
plans, like PDFs and things?
Do you have all that?
STUDENT 6: Yes,
so we're actually
in contact with Boston College
Disabilities Office right now,
and they are working
with the head architect
to get the information.
Right now we're just working
through the legal procedures
of which information
he's actually
allowed to give us and so
what we're allowed to display.
PROFESSOR 5: MIT has
a whole database.
If you ever want MIT,
I'll show you where it is.
AUDIENCE: How does he update
it, like if a pothole is fixed.
DIRK: Yeah, so that's
an area that we're still
trying to figure out.
We've had a couple
a different ideas,
one being trying to
crowdsource that out somehow,
having the ability
in the app for users,
if they notice something,
to put that in as an alert.
We've thought about
contacting Boston College,
like the maintenance or
the facilities office,
and if their staff
notices things,
having a way to put that in.
So those are a couple
ideas, and we're still
trying to figure out
exactly how the best
way to go about that is.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me,
we have a colleague
in New York City that's
done, in the past,
maybe two or three years
ago, like a Yelp for people
with disabilities for
accessibility to buildings.
I'm fairly sure the
site no longer as fresh
as it was during his
NYU [? ITP ?] days,
but we could put you
in touch with them
and see how they've updated or
how they basically populated
that information.
DIRK: Yeah, that would be great.
CIMMY: Hi, we're Team Felicity.
I'm Cimmy.
This Ari.
This is Becca, and
we're Team Felicity.
This is our mid-semester review.
Today we're going to
show you our video, talk
about the HAAT
model for Felicity,
our project vision, and
our accomplishments so far.
So we'll start off by
showing you our video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Let's like together
develop a prototype
of assistive technology
that you will find useful.
-I have a disease called
neurofibromatosis,
which causes tumors to build
up in the brain and spine.
I had surgery last
February in 2014
to remove the tumor on this
side, which also took out
my hearing nerve completely,
so now absolutely profoundly
deaf on each side.
I also have a tumor on my
optic nerve behind this eye.
My vision, I have days where
my vision is perfectly fine,
and I can see
everything clearly.
Then I have other days where
things are just like really
cloudy and I lose
depth perception
or have trouble seeing
like walk signals,
like seeing whether it's
white or red or flashing.
And I had a really close call
a few weeks ago over in Fenway,
where, because I
know I'm impaired,
so I'm looking for the light,
and I still kind of like
look because I just
don't trust anyone.
But I look for the light,
and then a big truck
comes right towards me.
It was terrifying.
I pretty much rely on like
reading people's lips,
and then I'll take
out pen and paper
if it's like something that's
really, really important
or if I'm just
particularly tired
and don't have the energy.
I'm moving to a new
apartment on October 1st,
and they're installing flashing
smoke detectors, CO detector,
and a doorbell.
I've never used a
flashing doorbell before,
so that will be exciting.
I can feel the vibes.
And I have like a
computer that I watch
captioned DVDs on sometimes.
I don't have a TV or radio.
I set my phone to vibrate all
the time for when I get emails
and so forth.
If I call you, then they'll
be a relay operator.
-I'm doing fine.
Thanks for asking.
Go ahead.
-Hi, I'm Ari.
Hi, I'm Cimmy.
Hey, I'm Becca, and
we're Team Felicity.
We've gotten to know Felicity a
lot better through our meetings
and have come up with
a lot of neat ideas.
We're excited to get going.
[END PLAYBACK]
CIMMY: So, as you
can see, Felicity
has neurofibromatosis, which
is a genetic disorder that
can causes tumors to
grow on nerve tissue.
She had a few surgeries
to take away some tumors,
and due to those surgeries,
she lost a lot of her vision.
She can use her
peripherals, and she's
profoundly deaf on both sides.
The activities that
Felicity likes to do
are she really enjoys
walking around Boston.
She also actually has routine
doctor's appointments,
so she's usually between
our home and the hospital.
And in terms of
context, Felicity
lives alone at her apartment.
She is unemployed
and frequents doctors
offices and the hospital.
And she leaves the house
minimally during evening.
She doesn't like
to be out at night.
And she happens to be
very open to letting
people know that she
is deaf and using
assistive technology
between that.
In terms of assistive
technology that Felicity already
uses, so to
communicate with her,
we have been using a notepad
or a laptop with size 36 font
so she can read it.
And she also uses her iPhone,
as you saw on the video.
She receives emails
from her doctor
when she's out the doctor's
office to notify her
when they're ready for her.
And she uses a Sprint relay
app for phone calls and so on.
And, as you saw on the video,
a flashing smoke detector,
and a CO alarm are
installed in her home,
and she also has a flashing
doorbell, which the noise is
loud enough that she actually
feel the vibrations when
they're occurring.
So now I'll switch
over to Becca.
BECCA: So I guess along
the way of getting
to know Felicity
and her daily life,
we like discussed
a lot of activities
that we could potentially help
her design an AT solution for.
We had to kind of whittle
it down to one motivation
that we could center
a project around.
And so the problem that
we're going to focus on
is that Felicity can't always
detect when events occur
because she's mostly deaf.
And so these include like
if people call her name,
either at a cafe or at
the doctor's office,
or if a laundry
machine's done, or when
she's going on her walks,
she can't hear cars
honking from incoming traffic.
And so these are
all situations where
somehow RET could help her.
And so our goal
for the project is
to develop an AT that
will notify Felicity
when particular events happen.
So this is variation came
particularly from an email
that Felicity sent to us with
this hearing dogs video in it.
I guess we don't have
time to show the video,
but the idea was just that she
saw this hearing dog video,
and at the end of
her email she said,
it would be really
cool if I could have
my own handheld hearing dog.
And so that was a cool
step towards, for us,
to find a solution for her.
And so throughout so
far, we've currently
been going through an
iterative design process
to kind of whittle
go down a solution
and find something
that works for her.
We've been using low
fidelity prototypes
to get feedback from
Felicity, even to narrow down
for our project solution.
And as we'll talk
about a little later,
our initial design
process showed us
that our project problem changed
after discussions with her.
So this is just some example
of some of the sketches
we've done.
In this example, we had
two parts of a solution.
One was a button that someone
could pass for her attention,
and the other would be some
sort of wearable device
that would vibrate, telling
her once like this button has
been pushed.
Now Ari is going to
share a little bit more
about our initial problem
statement and problem overview.
ARI: Right, so the first
project we wanted to tackle
was trying to let Felicity
know when someone called out
her name.
And because she can't hear
and she has limited vision,
it's pretty difficult if
she was in like a waiting
room or the doctor's
office or in a classroom
to like figure out if someone's
trying to contact her.
So the idea we came up with
was rather than having someone
try to call out their name, we
would have them have a button
that they could press.
And when they press
the button, it
would contact Felicity
that they were
trying to get her attention.
So this is the kind of
overview of that design.
We have a button that
someone could press.
It would send a
message to her iPhone,
and then the iPhone
would display
some sort of notification.
And then we'd also
have a wearable device
that she could use, and they
both display notifications.
So kind of a two-step
notification.
Luckily, we really worked
on doing iterative design
and also user-centered
design because we
try talking with her
about how well does
she think this will work, and
she really liked this idea.
But she was concerned about
other people using it.
And so one thing we
tried talking with her
is what would you like more?
And particularly, she
would want something
that she could use possibly more
often and also independently
because this original project
involves two clients-- Felicity
and whoever we
give the button to.
And so the new
focus of our project
changed to try and
make some sort of way
to make sound emitting
appliances within her home
accessible for Felicity.
So basically within
Felicity's apartment
she has a few different
household appliances
that she doesn't know
when they're done working.
In particular, the laundry
machine, when it's done,
it just triggers a beep,
and it doesn't have a timer.
So she would like a way to
know when it's finished.
And basically the
idea we have is
we could have some
sort of device
that she could place next
to the household appliance.
And then when the
appliance is finished
doing whatever its task is,
it will emit some noise,
and this device
would pick up on it
and send a signal
to Felicity to let
her know that whatever
the household appliance
task has completed.
So again, we kind of kept
last half of the project
that we started scoping
out and just talking about.
And instead, now we
have a microphone
that would be placed next
to the household appliance,
and then the microphone would
be sending sound to the iPhone.
And within the iPhone we
could have an application
that would notify when the
sound of the appliance finishing
has happened.
So for the
implementation we decide
to use Bluetooth because
this is in her apartment.
It's less than 30
feet, and also Felicity
leaves her phone plugged in
while she's at her house.
So we're not too
worried about that part.
And then right now we're all
working on developing an iPhone
application for detecting
the sound and also
the Bluetooth integration.
So these are kind of
the hardware pieces
we've been also testing out.
The first one was a Bluetooth
camera shutter button,
and we also have a
headset that we're just
using as a microphone
because we already have it,
and we're just trying to
do low-cost prototyping.
BECCA: So to talk a little
bit about the success metrics
that we set up for our project,
for the technical side,
we broke down our
project in two parts.
There's going to be a noise
detection to the iPhone part,
and then the iPhone to
the notification part.
And so from there, we
have like two activities--
the amount of noise
that this microphone
could withstand before, and also
correctly detect the appliance.
And those are kind of
our levels of how good
it would be, where level
two would be ideal,
and level zero is not actually
doing its job, and then
the number of noises
it would detect.
And then for the iPhone
to notification part,
the success metric would
be like the percent
times the notification actually
succeeds and is correctly
pinging Felicity.
And then we have for
overall performance,
I guess the best way to
measure our success is
just how many appliances we
can actually adapt this to.
And so the laundry machine,
dryer, toaster oven,
and tea pot are just
five things that we
are kind of aiming towards
being able to make this for.
And also we're considering
maintenance as well.
Once we finish
with this project,
we want to make sure that
all the parts of our project
are replaceable so that
Felicity can continue
to use it once we're not there.
From the UI perspective side,
the best way quantitatively
to measure this is
just the average time
it would take to set up a
notification for a machine task
that she has, and then
also her own perspective
about whether or not
she things the UI
is intuitive and easy to use.
CIMMY: And in terms of our
project development so far,
we have purchased at Bluetooth
camera shutter remote button,
which was actually
for our previous idea,
in order for Felicity to be
able to give a button to someone
so that they could press
it to a signal her phone
that she's getting a signal.
And we started developing
an iPhone application
for the project that
we've moved towards,
and now we're investigating
wearable devices that Felicity
could wear for notification.
And we're leaning
more towards the side
of some sort of wrist
wearable or something
that she could hold.
And in terms of our project's
plans and timelines,
this is just a general
timeline that we have.
We hope to get her iPhone
app working at a low scale
so that we can just have
her iPhone connected
with some microphone and see
how well that works, if we're
getting a vibration
notification,
gather appliances and a sound
library by November 7th,
and then test the
app functionality.
We want to focus a lot on
having Felicity test out the app
and see how well it works.
And then probably by
the 28th of November,
we want to clean up the final
project and work on the UI
and fix bugs on the last week.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 4: Questions
and comments?
AUDIENCE: So for the appliances
you were talking about,
like tea pot, laundry,
and [INAUDIBLE],
would it make more sense
to use a timer for that?
Because each of those
appliances are pretty set
timings for the [INAUDIBLE].
Would that be easier than
detecting a sound [INAUDIBLE]?
BECCA: So that's something
that we asked Felicity about,
and I think she-- oh sorry.
That is something we
asked, we brought up
when we were talking about
this is with Felicity.
But, I think, one thing
is like you don't always
remember to set up the
timer, or sometimes
you just like run into
something else that you do.
And so you told yourself,
oh, I was going to do that.
But she just forgets.
And also when she's home, she
doesn't keep her iPhone on her.
So she usually
has it plugged in,
so if she can't hear the alarm,
or even if it was vibrating,
she just doesn't know
if she's in another room
or she's taking a nap to
actually go and check on it.
So I think when we did
introduce this idea to her,
and we told her, well, there
are like other alternatives that
seem more feasible,
she really liked
the idea of having
something that's preferably
a wearable that just vibrates.
Then she doesn't have
to be thinking about it.
But she'll know exactly
when it's ringing that she
should go back and see it.
AUDIENCE: Why do
you need the phone?
BECCA: So I think first in
terms of like implementation,
it's a bit easier
to have an iPhone
app be the one that's sending
the Bluetooth signal back
to the wearable.
And also in terms of
modularity, I think,
it would be a more
complicated hardware solution
if it was intelligently
picking up just
to send to the specific
hardware device.
I'm sorry, from like sound
detector to the wearable,
it's two more complicated
hardware solutions.
And so then it's the
question of maintenance,
like how is she going
to replace these more
complicated solutions?
But instead, we're
using two kind
of just all they have to do is
either send a Bluetooth signal
and then receive a
Bluetooth signal,
and that's like two much cheaper
hardware pieces for us to get.
And she could always
replace those.
And then the iPhone
app is something
that she'd already have.
AUDIENCE: How much is
a Bluetooth switch?
BECCA: Yeah, so what
we looked at so far,
like out-of-the0box solutions
to be like $30 to $40.
AUDIENCE: If you
skip the phone, I
guess, you would be able
to use an RF link for $5?
BECCA: OK, but would
that be able to know--
like would the
notification collector,
I mean the sound detector,
know to send it exactly
to this Bluetooth wearable?
Or is that a Bluetooth
[INAUDIBLE] RF?
ARI: I guess one thing
we'd also like to include
is one of the reasons we
kind of stuck with iPhone
is we were interested in finding
commercial products that we
don't have to customize
any of the hardware,
especially with
the button design.
If it broke, she could
easily purchase a new one.
Like those buttons that we
first shows, they're under $10
to get similar designs.
So what we're
really hoping to get
is something that
will work after we're
done with the class.
So you can purchase
these designs
and keep making designs that
work with the iPhone, then
why don't we capitalize on that?
PROFESSOR 4: So, Leonard,
do you have a question?
PROFESSOR 5: Did you
make an actual prototype
for-- what was your prototype?
BECCA: It was mostly so
far just like sketches.
It was mostly
sketches to show her
like, OK, these are
three pieces, two pieces,
or like, these are kinds of
pieces we're talking about,
and then like whether or
not you even like the idea.
PROFESSOR 5: Sort of
like a storyboard?
BECCA: Yeah, and
user [? flows. ?]
ARI: And we also brought
the physical hardware
of that button to kind of
see how she liked it, would
she feel like it's OK to use.
PROFESSOR 5: So you're
going to run with that one?
The you bought, is that
what you're going to use,
or are you going to
use something else?
ARI: No, we're
planning on switching
to try to make something
that only works
with her independently because
we're concerned about having
the extra client that
couldn't really control,
make sure they were on board.
BECCA: So it's like
microphone, iPhone, and then
wearable or something
to like [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 5: OK, I
think we're at time.
Thank you very much.
EANN: Hi, we're Team
Don, and my name is Eann.
This is Christina,
and over here is Jan.
First, we'd like to tell
you a little bit more
about our client.
Our client's name is Don, and
he is a male senior citizen
who currently lives alone.
He's a strong advocate
for support groups,
and he constantly tells us
about how he goes to conferences
and speaks to health
professionals.
And he suffered from polio
during his childhood,
and that is affected
his left leg.
But in 2002, he also
suffer from a stroke
that affected the right
hemisphere of his brain.
So currently he has limited use
of his left side and especially
his left arm, and
this has also resulted
in cognitive
difficulties, especially
in the late afternoon
or early afternoon,
whenever sometimes it's a
little bit harder for him
to process and to focus
and to just kind of stay
on track with
whatever conversation
he's currently engaged in.
From our very first meeting,
we knew that Don loved food,
and he loved to cook.
So one of our very
first questions
was, what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream?
And this kind of transcended
into this conversation of food,
and we discovered
that Don was actually
a food catering manager
prior to his disability.
And when you first
started at his job at KFC,
he learned about his passion for
cooking and expressing himself
through food.
And so as a result,
he still cooks,
and he constantly talks
about different recipes.
And we got the opportunity
to make omelettes
with him one day.
And so with his left hand,
it typically is stable,
and he uses his
right hand to cook.
And with his left hand
held typically either
brace apart or hold
onto a cheese package,
and rip open the top.
But typically, it's
only just his right arm
that he uses, and
it's essentially
his only method of cooking--
or only manner of cooking.
And so this you can see is
in his actual apartment.
We got the opportunity to go
visit Don in his apartment
and kind of see where he lives
and see where he actually
takes the time to cook.
And so we noticed
that is apartment
is actually-- his kitchen
is actually fairly small.
It is about the size of a small
kitchen in Burton Conner, which
is a dorm on campus.
And you can see
in the next slide
that the stove is fairly
close to the sink,
and so it's a pretty
small quarter for cooking.
And he's looking
for a way to improve
the mobility in his kitchen.
The assistive
technology that Don uses
includes Velcro, which
is on the left hand side.
He constantly tells us
that Velcro is his friend,
and he uses Velcro
for his shoes.
And on the far
right side, he also
uses a leg brace
that prevents him
from hyperextending his knee.
But the most important assistive
technology that he uses
is in the center, his iPhone.
So you can see, he's clearly
really excited about it,
and he's constantly using it to
schedule tasks, to send emails,
and he depends on this iPhone to
remind him of his daily tasks.
So in addition to
those three items,
he also uses a cane
to help him walk.
And so this is a quick
video of him using his cane,
and it's just simply
to help him walk
and to assist him
in being mobile.
JAN: So some challenges
we've already
seemed to have
faced in this design
project is our team scheduling.
So it's really hard for
us three to get together
with Don at the same time, same
place, and get something going.
And with Don's
cognitive overload,
he also has issues
focusing and telling us
what he really wants for
us to do on our project.
So we initially started
out with two projects
that we were going to work for
helping him with his cooking.
As you can see here, we
started off thinking of ways
that we can help him
out in the kitchen.
So something that
he did mention to us
was the fact that he needs
some help carrying big pots.
So since he has one
arm, it's really hard
to actually stabilize the
pot and move it from point A
to point B without
having the contents spill
and move around too much.
And another thing that was
mentioned to us by-- oh, he's
not here today-- another one
of the actual participants
of this class,
Jeffrey, was something
used for stirring or
stabilizing the pot
whenever he's either
stirring or doing something
with the contents of the pot.
And we initially started off
with two different projects
that we were going
to test out with Don
and figure out what he really
wanted out of us in this class.
So the first one was the
stability of the mixing pot
or doing something
with the pot or a bow.
And we decided that we wanted
to focus on these three
little things, so minimizing
how much the bowl moves,
how much it tips over, and
making sure that whatever
we use is fast and easy to use.
And as for moving
pots, we wanted
to focus more on how he can
take these pots from point A
to point B, so large pots with
a lot of things inside of them,
and minimize how
much effort he has
to put into moving these
things and stabilizing them,
while making it very
easy to use as well
and minimizing how
much liquid falls off
or how many things could
go wrong with this.
So we initially started off
with some design prototypes
for the stirring or for slipping
is something that we called it.
So we started for
slipping, and we showed him
some of these designs, and we
got some very good feedback
from him.
He was very, very opposed
to having something
big and clunky in his
desk or his workspace
whenever he was cooking.
And we used that to
further our designs
and make sure that we go with
something smaller, something
that doesn't get in the way and
is very easy for him to use.
And after that,
we showed him some
of the things that he may
want to use for moving a pot.
So over here, we
can see something
that can adjust to a pot
and use some sort of strap
around his forearm or
shoulder to move the pot.
Because he mentioned that
he has some what we thought
were really big
pots to move around
for a pretty long distance.
This was before we actually
went over to his house
and found out what
we were working with.
And another thing that
we thought was maybe-- he
says he slides the pots a
lot because it's a lot harder
for him to carry them.
Something that we
thought of was maybe
having a little mobile
station for him to use,
where he can slide the pot onto
it, slide it across the floor,
and then move it onto
the actual stove itself.
And finally, this is just some
brainstorming/prototyping.
We thought of like those
things that drummers use,
where they attach
it to their chest,
and you can pot in there.
But this is just
for brainstorming.
We just threw ideas out there.
And we showed
these ideas to Don,
and we decided
that we were going
to go much further into the
actual movement of the pot,
rather than the
stirring, since he
says that that's one of the
big challenges that he has.
And that's where we
are currently at.
We have identified the
problem and know what we're
going to do from here on out.
CHRISTINA: So this
past Friday we
actually got to go
to Don's apartment
to actually see what
his kitchen is like
and what his cooking
environment is like.
And so before we were
initially imagining
that he was using pots
that were like this big
and that you would need to
use like two hands to carry.
But we actually found
out that they're actually
normal sized pots which you
can carry with one hand,
and also the thing about his
kitchen space being very small
made some of our initial
designs not feasible.
So here you can see a
video of Don in action.
So, as you can see,
Don has trouble
moving filled pots from
his sink to his stove top
without having some of
the contents spill out.
And so we kind of made a
sketch of his kitchen layout.
And so the task requirement
that we decided on
was that we wanted to
help him be able to lift
and move the filled pot and also
not spill any of the contents.
And so these are
success metrics.
Them metrics include lifting
and moving the pot vertically
as well as horizontally, and
then the amount of spill there
is , and also how much time it
takes for him to move the pot
from the sink to his stove top.
And so we kind of evaluated
the current state of how
he accomplishes the task, and
we used a scale from 1 to 10,
one being we would
really like to help
him improve in this aspect,
and 10 being this is OK,
and this is great.
So we have our current goals, or
we have the current situation,
and we have the target.
And we also have
our reached goals.
So our contributions
up to date--
since we haven't really gotten
into the prototyping part yet,
we have all been designing
and brainstorming together.
And so Jan has been
facilitating the meetings.
Eann has been documenting
and taking notes,
and I have been taking
videos and also photos.
And for our future
contributions,
we are going to continue doing
what we're doing right now.
Also, once we get a better idea
of what are design will be,
maybe split up
the tasks for what
different components
of our product
that we are going
to be working on.
So I guess like our
most crucial step
is our next step, which is
like in the immediate future.
So we really need to
be able to come up
with a design for our first
prototype and get it to Don
and get his feedback on it.
So one of the main things
that we will be focusing on
for this first prototype will
be mechanisms and concepts
for how he can move a
pot from a certain height
to a higher place.
And also, we might be
considering the material
that we will be using
the product because that
relates to, I guess, like
how much mass he can move.
And we will also be doing a
more quantitative evaluation
of Don's skills, so maybe like
how much mass he can life,
or how long can he
hold up a pot for.
And so I these are
our project plans.
So, as I mentioned before,
our main thing right now
is to get our first prototype
out and get his feedback on it.
And then from then on,
we can add more details
into our planning for how we are
going to finish this product.
PROFESSOR 5: Any questions?
Great, thank you.
PROFESSOR 6: Did he
articulate any other scenarios
of where her would move the
pot, aside from stove to sink?
JAN: No, that's the
only one we actually
saw him doing physically.
But I imagine that he would have
to potentially move something
that has like maybe spaghetti
to cool it down somewhere else
and maybe actually serving
my the pot, so from his
to the kitchen table.
But that's the only one
we actually saw him doing,
and that's why we are going to
get some further tests to see
distance, weight, and other
things that could potentially
play into our design.
PROFESSOR 6: So I
was wondering that
about how that may
impact your metrics
or quantitative metrics of being
able to move it three feet.
AUDIENCE: Maybe you
want to try to try
to get him to fill
the pot and move it
while there's hot liquid because
that may make a big difference.
And he was very aloof
about splashing cold water,
but he might not want to
do that with boiling water.
JAN: No, we didn't want
anybody to get hurt there.
AUDIENCE: Did you guys
try the pot-moving thing
yourselves to see
how much-- you filled
the pot all the way to the top.
How feasible is it for
like one of you to do that?
JAN: No, we did not.
It's something that
we should have done.
You're right.
PROFESSOR 5: So imagine
everything goes amazingly well.
What will you actually make?
What will you actually do?
Will it be a redesigned pot?
Is it sort of like thinking
about the procedure
of how to do these tasks?
You can imagine building
a robot that could do it.
It would be like really hard.
What are you
actually going to do?
JAN: So what really
thought was an attachment
that you can adjust to
almost any type of pot.
So one that I showed
over there was something
that you can put around
the top side of the pot,
so a belt or some
type of thing, where
it hooks on to the
top of the pot,
and you have belt on top
of it, where he can--
he says he would really like
to be able to really use
his forearm because his fingers
also get really tired, to be
able to put the belt over his
arm and then carry it over,
using that, rather
than the handle,
where he doesn't have
as much stability.
PROFESSOR 1: I do want to
echo what was said over here
about heat.
I think that the fact
that you didn't mentioned
that at all in your success
metrics or in your constraints
is actually a pretty
serious problem, right?
He's moving a pot to his
sink-- I'm sorry to the stove
in order to heat it up.
And then if he's going to
continue to be independent,
he's going to have
to do something
with that hot, still heavy pot.
So you need a
consideration here which is
that he doesn't burn himself.
And I think that
spillage may be something
that you should give a little
less concern to because that
can be solved by not filling it
up as much because that would
boil over anyway, if you filled
it up as much as he actually
did in that video or
by putting lids on it.
But I really would encourage
you to worry much more
and pay much more attention
to the problem of heat.
JAN: That's something
that we'll definitely
take into account then.
AUDIENCE: Especially
if you're going
in the direction of
putting something
that's close to his body.
And you can do tests
with him not burning him,
like put food coloring.
Have him wear something he
doesn't care about, and see
if he an immediate reflex if
he's spilling food coloring
on his clothes.
It'll give you a better
sense of is he really
that confident with this
forearm, for instance.
PROFESSOR 5: So it's
a really hard problem.
In some ways, I'll
just be honest,
like when I first saw
this compelling client,
and it's like, this
is a great person.
It would be great
to help him, and I
know that he loves to cook.
But dealing with pots full
of water, possibly hot water,
that just seems like
a really hard problem.
And I wonder if
there's something else
you can do for him that's not
so physically, like something
that doesn't have
a safety dimension.
You don't want to
give him something
he's going to burn himself
with badly on his own.
You know what I mean?
JAN: Yeah, we could also take
the alternative approach,
the actual stirring or moving
the things within the pot.
PROFESSOR 5: Or
maybe he just lets
it cool for a really long time.
But how do you get the food out?
I don't know.
Maybe there's a way to
rethink the entire-- I mean,
the goal is to have cooked food.
Is there a way to rethink
how you get cooked food
at the end of the day
that avoids lifting
a heavy pot from the sink.
AUDIENCE: Have a longer hose.
AUDIENCE: That's another
way to do the filling right?
PROFESSOR 5: You can
imagine filling it
with like small--
you know, a ferry
system of smaller
things that get
added a little bit at a time.
AUDIENCE: Or an interesting
pump [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 5: If you can sort of
train him how to do the task.
I wonder if there
are experts out there
in the world that figure
out how to do this.
Disabled cooking, is
there such a thing?
But I admire you
for taking it on.
It just seems really
hard and dangerous.
PROFESSOR 4: Great,
thank you, Team Don.
Thanks again.
We managed to get
through them all.
We have maybe two or
three minutes left.
Maybe I'll ask if the
panelists or the support staff
have general comments on
all the presentation today,
for the panelists here today.
And Professor Miller, if you
have general comments or advice
on the presentations or the
project progress in general,
give you the
opportunity to do that.
But while you think about
that, just one reminder
is to remember to upload your
slides from the presentation
today, so that we can integrate
these things into the video,
and so that we can look
at your slides as well.
And then the reports
are due Friday,
and then next week, we'll
have read all the reports,
and we'll give you some more
written feedback, a letter
grade at this point in time.
But I'll of the
panelists, Jose or Anna,
Professor Leonard,
Professor Miller,
if you have any general
comments or advice for teams
at this point in time.
PROFESSOR 1: Great to see the
progress that you're making.
Keep meeting with your
clients, and focus
on trying to finish that
prototype that you're
going to deliver at the
end of the semester.
PROFESSOR 5: I would
just say, like I've
taught design classes
and mechanical and ocean
engineering, and it's
really challenging
when the schedule crunch
at the end of the semester,
and so sometimes
you're going to have
to down scope towards the end.
But if you try to really think
about a measurable result,
that you really
accomplish something,
and what that would be, and make
sure you at least get that far.
Like it would be a disaster
if you didn't at least do x.
What is x?
Have a prototype that
does something, that gives
some value to your client.
And so the time's going
to go really quickly,
and you're going
to run out of time.
PROFESSOR 6: I would say
it's great to that you all
are meeting what seems
like a regular basis
with your collaborators
for these projects.
And so take advantage
of every time
you're meeting with
them to bring something
you can hold in your hand
that is going to impact
the final design, whether
a potential material
you could use, a prototype
of a looks-like design,
or this is a feature design.
But that'll really
help you to continue
to iterate on those features.
AUDIENCE: I would echo
Professor Leonard's comments
of take something.
If you're going towards
the end of the semester,
pick that one item
that you know is going
to make a critical difference.
If you spend too much
time picking pots,
we know what pots look
like, and how they behave.
But if you don't know how
another mechanism that you're
designing behaves,
then focus on that one.
And just in case you
do run out of time,
you know that that's an
addressable thing to leave out.
Don't leave out the
[? core ?] [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 4: Michelle,
[INAUDIBLE], Grace,
you have general comments?
OK, cool.
I think one thing I'll
say is I think you all
have gotten to know your
clients really well,
from the presentations.
On Monday and Wednesday and on
Friday night or on the weekend,
Grace and I watched all the
videos that where submitted.
We're all very impressed.
You really have
spent a lot of time
and really gotten
to know the people.
One thing I would
suggest is you really,
maybe in the next couple
weeks, really, really get
to know the client's task.
I mean really break
it down and come up
with these measurable
metrics, try things out,
food color the water, things
like that, so you can really
get a sense of
whether your device
or whether the system you're
building is going to work.
PROFESSOR 5: Like really
put yourself in their shoes.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, I think
that's pretty much it.
Next week we're going to do
a bunch of electronic device
labs, so bring your
laptop computer
is what we're hoping
for people to bring.
Grace, you have a
final announcement?
GRACE: Yeah, we sent
out a poll today.
We're going to set up twice
weekly hobby shop office hours.
So if you think you're going
to be using a hobby shop
or building anything mechanical,
please fill out the-- we'll
decide by Friday what
those office hours are.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR 4: And
Monday's class lecture
and lab will both
be in this room
because we're doing these
electronic device access
labs, so 32044 at both
1:00 PM and 3:00 PM.
OK, thanks.